Also Leute, ich bin wieder am Start, ich bin quasi off gestern, bin ich ins Bett, hab gepennt,
bin ich wieder on, um nicht zu sagen, ey ja Michael, glaub ich dir aufs Wort, ihr wisst
doch, der Server Admin, der schläft nicht, er ruht, Pains Champ, ich weiß, richtig schlechter
Joke, ne, Abtime seit 18 Tagen, Hacker Man Abtime, ich muss sagen, solch gut hab ich
nicht geschlafen, ich mein, es ist ja auch ungewohnt, außerdem ist immer mal wieder,
mal hat was draußen geknallt, aber es war wirklich wenig, es war im Vergleich zu sonst
war sowas von wenig Feuerwerk, also das kannst du gar nicht Feuerwerk nennen, war eigentlich
nix.
Haben sie in Köln eigentlich alle Lichter an und aus gemacht, muss ich jetzt mal kurz
gucken, Köln, ob das geklappt hat, genau, hat das funktioniert?
Silvester Fenster, ok, das muss ich mal kurz auf Twitter gucken, ob das funktioniert hat.
Tatsächlich, die Leute haben mitgemacht, oh, boah, riecht advanced mit RGB hier, guckt
euch das an, na wobei, ja doch, RGB, sind immer in 3 verschiedene Farben, oder das blaue
ist kaputt gegangen danach, aber es hat kaum einer mitgemacht, guckt mal, es hat kaum
einer mitgemacht, kann das sein, es hat keiner mitgemacht, lul, das ist der einzige Typ hier,
naja gut, Idiots, ja, wie gesagt, mehr als 3 Raketen waren es bei uns auch nicht.
Äh, das ist ne gute Frage, machen wir kurz den Chat auf, ach nee, bringt ja nix, wenn
ich den Chat nachträglich aufmache, Flo690 fragt hier, Max, ich hab mal eine wichtige
Frage, wenn du 7 Wochen am Stück Urlaub hast, wie schaffst du es dein Schlafrhythmus beizubehalten?
Ich glaube, das liegt, also ich krieg das hin, halbwegs, ja, ich glaub, das liegt daran,
weil ich normalerweise auch circa so aufstehe, wie es halt so meine innere Uhr will, und
das mach ich im Urlaub auch, normalerweise geh ich so spätestens 23 Uhr ins Bett und
steh dann so, keine Ahnung, 7 Uhr auf, oder 7.30 Uhr, je nachdem, also seit ich Homeoffice
hab, und das mach ich jetzt ungefähr auch, wenn ich Urlaub hab, dementsprechend stört
mich das nicht, hä, warum löscht du eigentlich immer die 1 in der Zeit, tja, das ist, weil
ich sie nicht mehr alle hab, das hat keinen tieferen Grund, wir haben sogar, wir haben
sogar, guck mal, wir haben sogar ein Kommando für, wo ich das mal versucht hab zu erklären,
guck mal, meine Videos werden mittlerweile empfohlen, was ist denn hier los, source code
to task manager, who cares denn, der task manager, also ich könnt mir in Windhaus kaum
was uninteressantes vorstellen, als den task manager source code mir anzugucken, lechak
1,9,7,8, 13 Monate, ai ai ai, guckt euch das mal an, 13 Monate, massive, weiter gehts
in 21, also 2020 remastered, oder 2020 ti, super, ah yes, Leute, ich muss euch mal was
zum, oder umgedreht, soll ich euch mal was zum kecken zeigen, zum richtig, zum eine Runde
zum aufwachen, eine Runde kecken, so, und zwar, soll ich euch mal was zum kecken, und
zwar hat mir einer auf Twitter geschickt, die haben nen Beitrag gemacht, also wir gucken
uns nicht den ganzen Beitrag an, wir gucken uns nur 30 Sekunden draus an, ja, erst ist
das wahrscheinlich sonst monka Toss und es ist übelst langweilig, es hat mir einer auf
Twitter diesen Beitrag geschickt vom SWR, und passt mal auf, passt mal auf, so, das ist
alles langweilig, wir müssen mal zu, äh, wo ist der Hacker Experte, irgendwann kommt
der Hacker Experte, wo ist der Hacker Experte, ich muss euch nämlich zeigen, was die auf
ihrem Terminal haben, ich glaub, ich glaub der Hacker Experte ist hier irgendwann am
Start, mein Freund, ich muss mal gucken, wo der Hacker Experte kommt, weil ihr müsst
mal gucken, was der Dude auf dem, 11 Monate stellt, so, dankeschön, richtig nice, bei
einer Minute ungefähr ist der Hacker Mann am Start, also, gucken wir mal, wir gucken
mal die erste Minute, das ist schon Pains Champ ohne Ende, ja, ooooh, ich finde das
immer geil, wie die das, wie die solche Intros machen, so nach dem Motto, sieht es bei einem
Zuhause schon bald so aus, es ist vielleicht die Möglichkeit, das nicht grandiose, übertriebene
Boomer-SWR-Gucker, dass es bei denen daheim schon so aussieht, ja, das ist Schwachsinn,
das braucht keiner, Knopf drucken, weil, du musst ja eh da sein, um Kaffee zu trinken,
wie gesagt, ich will nur eineinhalb Minuten gucken, ihr müsst euch nämlich mal was angucken,
da lacht ihr euch kaputt, ok, der Meh-Roboter, ja, das lasse ich mir noch gefallen, wobei
Meh-Roboter halt nur funktioniert, wenn du wirklich auch so einen Garten hast, wenn du
einen normalen Garten hast, wo auch mal eine Wurzel ist oder sowas und das nicht exakt
gerade mit dem Lineal gezogen ist, dann klappt das natürlich nicht.
Und auch Kochbücher sind in einem solchen Haushalt überflüssig, dann erstmal schön
sein ganzes Ding mit Alexa ausstatten, da wisst ihr, ich bin kein großer Voice-Assistent-Fan,
Lachs-Lasagne mit Spinat, MonkaS, und das ist, und das triggert mich bei öffentlich-rechtlichen
Sendungen auch immer geil, krass, wenn die, na geil, geil nicht wirklich, ja, wenn die
irgendeinen Begriff sagen, dann sagen die immer, im sogenannten Smart Home, so, und
es ist dann so, was weiß ich, im sogenannten Treppenhaus oder so, im sogenannten Fahrstuhl,
in der sogenannten Taskleiste, im sogenannten Terminal, die sagen immer sogenannt davor,
im sogenannten öffentlichen Rundfunk, ja, in der sogenannten Lachs-Lasagne mit Spinat,
pass mal auf, aber gleich wird's lustig, Hexerei, pure Zauberei hier, war da von abgesehen,
dass die 30 Sekunden bei 9.54 anfangen, aber da wollen wir uns jetzt ja mal nicht so drüber
beschweren, gleich kommt der Hacker-Man, da ist der Hacker-Man.
Okay, gleich kommt der Hacker-Man, das ist, und dann haben sie immer noch Moderatorin
oder Moderatorin, die immer furchtbar interessiert gucken müssen, der Loch hinten, so, jetzt,
pass mal auf, das war echt geil, oder?
Das ist so schlecht, Alter, das ist so schlecht, die haben zu ihm gesagt, ich will ihm gar
nicht unterstellen, dass er keine Ahnung hat, was er macht, die haben zu ihm gesagt, wir
möchten sie mal kurz an der Tastatur beim Tippen filmen, tippen sie mal was, und hier
wollte er übrigens Vim schließen, ne, aber die coolen Leute machen ja Doppelpunkt X und
nicht QW, und die haben gesagt, tippen sie mal irgendwas auf der Tastatur, und dann hat
der krassen Hacker-Man gemacht, und die haben halt, die waren halt so doof, bei der Produktion
nicht die Tastatur da jetzt reinzuschneiden, sondern den Monitor, in der Hoffnung, das
ist sinnvoll, was der tippt, ja, wahrscheinlich haben die sich gar keinen Gedanken drüber
gemacht, aber das ist ja auf jeden Fall geil, den Rest muss man sich nicht geben, im Prinzip
geht es in diesem Beitrag, ich hab den Beitrag auch noch bis zur Hälfte geguckt, im Prinzip
geht es in diesem Beitrag, dass irgendwie ein Pärchen sein Haus in Smart Home umrüsten
will, und dann gehen sie in ein smartes Haus und lassen sich das zeigen und sind furchtbar
begeistert, und im Endeffekt entscheiden sie sich für die größte Kack-Technik überhaupt
und bauen sie in ihr Haus ein, so, die sinnloseste Fail-Technik aller Zeiten, sprich, sie haben
die Auswahl zwischen sich nicht an den Hersteller binden und erweiterbar bleiben, und was machen
sie, sie kaufen sich irgendwie so eine Closed-Source-Home-Matic-Lichter-Steuerung, was sonst nichts kann, richtig
Big Brain, vorher erzählen sie eine halbe Stunde, wie geil sie ihre Rollen automatisieren
wollen, alles mögliche machen wollen, dann krauben sie sich eine Home-Matic-Lichter-Steuerung,
aber jeder, jeder was er braucht, was er verdient, aber gut, was erwartet man von so einer Doku,
jeder Rest ist gar nicht schlecht, man muss ehrlich sagen, so mies ist die Doku gar nicht,
also das ist halt so typisch extrem vereinfacht, alles, aber das ist okay, ach ja, und, und,
die hoffen im Video mit 500 Euro hinzukommen, man muss mir ja sagen, allein schon für die
Rollansteuerung brauchen die ja für die Rolläden um ein Vielfaches mehr, wenn du das nachrüsten
willst, also wenn du Rolläden hast, die noch so richtig handbetriebmäßig funktionieren,
dann musst du ja entweder so einen Roller installieren, der den Kram per Motor hoch und
runter macht, oder du musst einen Motor einbauen in den Kasten oben, da kommst du mit 500 Euro
fürs ganze Haus im Leben nicht hin, da kommst du vielleicht für 500 Euro für 1-2 Rolläden
hin, wenn das ein paar Handwerker machen, also das ist scheuer, aber schon hart, ne, und
immer wenn ich solche Beiträge sehe, frage ich mich, was gibt es in diesen Beiträgen
noch, wovon ich keine Ahnung hab und was auch komplett falsch ist, gibt es eigentlich
eine Neujahrsansprache, Neujahrsansprache, ich will die jetzt nicht gucken, achja, 7
Minuten, oh ne, das ist mir zu lang, 7 Minuten Neujahrsansprache, das halt ich net aus, ähm,
wahrscheinlich ist die Neujahrsansprache im Prinzip ewig, also es ist ja mittlerweile
relativ predictable, ja, wahrscheinlich ist die Neujahrsansprache eh zu 90%, alle Leute
sollen sich mal ein bisschen am Rieben reißen und zusammenhalten und wir überstehen das,
so nach dem Motto, ja, was solls, was solls, solls großartig sein, ist nicht wirklich Neujahrs,
Neujahrsansprache, Bingo, das ist zu einfach, guck mal, diese Spiele haben 2020 nicht überlebt,
äh, das fällt mir immer, was, was ist was, es gibt ein paar Sachen, die gecancelt wurden,
gerade 2020, die haben viele Sachen verschoben, achja, achja, das, das, es gibt zwei Sachen,
die mir in Erinnerung geblieben sind, der Overwatch, der Overwatch-Klon von Amazon, falls sich da
noch irgendjemand dran erinnert, der ist vorbei und, und ich weiß, es ist nicht Closed, ich
weiß, es ist nicht Closed, aber es ist, es ist Dead Game, Hyperscape, kannst, kannst
ich auch noch jemand dran erinnert, Hyperscape, Alter, das war das Battle Royale von Ubisoft,
ja, die Hyperscape Emotes hab ich auch noch, aber das ist halt Dead, richtig Dead, das
gibt's noch, das gibt's noch, aber, aber, pass mal auf, wenn wir jetzt mal auf Twitch
gucken, gucken, nein, nein, nein, ich will mich nicht selbst hören, wir mal gucken, oh,
nicht mal, nicht mal ein Channel, Alter, nee, nee, German, German, ah, 13 Viewer, exellent,
ist ja voll, voll die Wucht, äh, ja, Battlefield 3 hat mehr Viewer als Hyperscape und wenn
du Hyperscape Reddit guckst, sind irgendwie 20 Leute an oder so, ja, ok, 40, 40, aber
es wird immerhin noch entwickelt, ne, Sorts und Hyperscape, die, die, die cacken sich
ne Runde und spielen weiter Apex, das ist, das ist auch so ein Ding, das stimmt zum größten
Teil gar nicht, aber wenn man ein Game wirklich lange Hardcore gegrindet hat, ab irgendwann
fängt's an keinen Bock mehr zu machen, das ist gar nicht so sehr, dass die Games wirklich
viel schlechter werden, es hängt einem zum Hals raus und dann sagt man immer, ja, bis
Season 3 war geil, danach war Shit, mag sicherlich die ein oder anderen Sachen geben, wo das
wirklich so ist, aber zum größten Teil ist man einfach, hat man einfach keinen Bock mehr,
ne, aber Hyperscape, also meine, meine Dead Games 2020 sind eindeutig Crucible und Hyperscape
gewesen, es gab natürlich ein paar Games, die ihren Hype nicht erfüllt haben, sowas
wie Cyberpunk, aber das wurde ja wenigstens nicht Canceled, wie gesagt Hyperscape auch
nicht wirklich, aber hat halt gefailt ohne Ende. Schauen wir mal an, was die GameStar dazu
zu sagen hat, kurz, mal gucken, mal gucken wer das Video macht, es gibt ein paar Leute
bei der GameStar, die kann ich mal angucken, aber immer unabstrich muss ich sagen, dass
die GameStar immer noch beste so Spiele-Magazin was gibt in Deutschland, ist halt mittlerweile
auch viel, ja, weiß nicht ob man das Clickbait nennen kann, bei der GameStar ist ja zumindest
noch der Inhalt meistens halbwegs dementsprechend, aber man hüpft halt bei der GameStar auch
ganz krass auf Zeug, was halt, ja, letztendlich Aufrufe generiert, aber das kann ich ihnen
gar nicht mal übel nehmen. OnKS. Game, Game, Gamer Grill, Leute.
Ja gut, die Leute haben daheim gesessen und haben gespielt, natürlich haben die Umsatz.
Ok, wir waren, Crucible, LOL, einmal zum Crucible, das beste, das erste was ich gesagt habe,
ein bisschen lauter. Achja, übrigens wisst ihr was, was auch ein
richtiger Fail 2020 war, kann sich noch einer an Wolzen erinnern, ich weiß bis heute gar
nicht wie man das ausspricht, wie spricht man das überhaupt aus, Wolken, was, Wolken,
ernsthaft, Wolzen, Wolzen, Wolzen, na egal, egal, das war 2020 auch richtig Fail, Wolzen,
ist das Final Fantasy, online, hier stehts, ja, die haben es verkackt, alter die haben
so krass verkackt mit Crucible, ja, ich frag mich auch bei Crucible, was sie sich dabei
gedacht haben, ich mein, spielen die, spielen die ihren Kram selber nicht, ich mein man
spielt doch, wenn man was entwickelt, spielt man es doch selbst und guckt sich das an,
vielleicht jetzt nicht jeder einzelne, alles, aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass man einfach
an was entwickelt, was man gespielt und da muss man noch merken, dass es einfach Crap
ist. Ja, und es hat gesagt, und es hat gesagt,
ok nagas,脱ht das anderes?
Die auf der wende und die spielerzahlen schrumpften auf einen niedrigen dreistelligen wert
Da hat man viel drei mehr die reißleine und ging zurück zur konzeption
crucible wurde zwei monate nach veröffentlichung wieder in die beta moment dreistellig moment moment ich habe keinen vierstich hab
gerade an an an an
1000 gedacht dreistellig dreistellig bedeuten maximal 999 ok das ist
also wenn wenn ich
Neujahrsmorgen mehr zuschauer als crucible spieler hat dann weißt du was schiefgelaufen ist
damit die gröbsten schwachstellen die shooters ausgebügelt werden konnten
Aber all die manöver fruchteten nur wenig im oktober kündigte der versandriese an die entwicklung komplett einzustellen und die server auszuknipsen
anscheinend hatte er keine hoffnung mehr doch noch die gunst der spielergemeinschaft zu gewinnen
Für gewöhnlich übernehmen wir in spielen die rolle als monster schlechter
Sagt mir gar nichts und bezwinger bösartige kreaturen die sich vor allem im schatten stimmt entem 2.0 kam das eigentlich mittlerweile raus
In dark born hätte sich unsere perspektive aber einmal um 180 grad gedreht
Im mittelpunkt stand ein unheimliches wesen mit spitzten zähnen und bleicher haut habe ich noch nie was von gehört
Am anfang des spiels töten wikinger seine mutter und es seine höhe verlässt und sich auf eine rache feldzug begibt die ersten spielstunden muss es
Im verborgenen bleiben und unbemerkt an den menschen vorbeischleichen weil es eine direkte konfrontation nicht überleben würde
Nur wenn es geschickt die umgebung nutzt und aus dem hinterhalt angreift hat es eine chance warum müssten sie immer wikinger sein
Nach und nach wird die dunkle kreatur aber immer stärker und größer
Irgendwann wächst sie zu einer zwei meter hohen bestie heran und kann den menschen und warum sehen wikinger immer gar nicht so aus wie wikinger der
Typ der kann seinen kopf überhaupt nicht drehen
All die brustjagen mehr als drei jahre lang egal fantasy meinetwegen lasst mir gefallen das an dark born trotz
Das ist so ist so wir haben skyrim skyrim models importiert und war ein game bereits fortgeschrittenen gameplay
Mechaniken gab das team im april bekannt die entwicklung gestoppt zu haben grüne nannten sie leider nicht sie würden aber mittlerweile an einem
Anderen projekt sitzen dass er voller aufmerksamkeit benötige dark borne musste deswegen erst mal zurück in die schatten
Okay, habe ich nichts von gehört macht noch lange kein erfolgreiches spiel das macht microsoft mit gears pop auf die harte turn was
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört hier ist pop
Was ist das überhaupt ich habe keine ahnung habe ich schon nie gehört habt ihr das schon mal gehört ist das free to play spiel im sommer 2019
Für pc android freeter play unter der erfolg hielt aber nicht lange an schon etwa ein jahr später verkündete der publisher das aus des
Gears ablegers aufgrund schrumpfender nutzerzahlen die server werden anfang 20 21
Ach das ist moment das ist gar kein gears das ist ein tower defense
Bis dahin können interessierte noch in das spiel reinschnuppern dass aller clash royale zwei parteien in einen simplen aber kurzweiligen
Stellungskampf verwickelt da wundert mich ja nichts mehr dass es nicht gut angekommen ist
Sieht man aus dem gears universum stammende figuren bespuren ja und das problem das problem dabei ist dass die gears figuren absolut uninteressant sind
also
Ohne scheiß sollte mir fällt kein game an wo story und charaktere
Mehr aufgesetzt wirkten nach dem nach dem ersten teil als gears so vor der erste teil gears so vor war gut
Weil im ersten teil gears so vor was halt exakt so gemacht wie es sein sollte
irgendwelche muskelstelle typen
besten halt aliens weg
So fertig so die braucht keine keine keine personality und nix die die gears so vor dudes
Ja, also ich krieg mein reißverschluss kaputt ich krieg meinen reißverschluss nicht auf
fack
scheiße
Ich muss ich muss mal kurz. Wir sind ein bisschen warm ich war kurz mein
Mein hemd hier ausziehen aber kein kein kein gachi bass hier
Mein hemd das falsche hab so eine Jacke drüber gehabt
So jagerausziehen jetzt bisschen warm drin genau also gears so vor ohne mist
Erster teil richtig geil und danach haben sie so voll auf story und emotional gemacht was halt zu gears nie gepasst hat
Und die charaktere in gears so vor sind halt so so flach ich sage euch meiner mein nach marcus phoenix das ist der schlechteste
shooter held aller Zeiten
Der ist halt einfach nur da im ersten teil um da zu sein der wurde erfunden um halt irgendwie so so so random da rein
Zu passen und ab dem zweiten teil haben sie dann versucht zu personality story und tiefgang und drama zu machen und das hat halt überhaupt nicht gepasst
Dementsprechend war gears so vor auch story mäßig mega langweilig
Deswegen will auch niemand mit gears so vor charakter spielen
Der beste der beste war immer noch berth alter berth kennt ihr immer noch noch berth berth aus gears so vor
Moment dass das ist eingestellt
Das wurde mir immer immer das wurde mir glaube ich im steamsale immer beworben
Er machte sein team er dachte nicht nur ein fundament aus spaßigen karteneffekten sondern auch ein damit verwobenes taktik spiel das beschwören und positionieren von monstern und anderen kreaturen war nämlich ein integrailles spielelement das übersieg oder niederlage in hardstone ist einfach hat es nun ist mittlerweile einfach alles random
Viele kritiken bescheinigten dem spiel eine enorme spiel tiefe und gründen duales zu einem der besten haas und magic konkurrenten
Trotz der vielen cleveren Ideen musste der Entwickler aber nach 4 Jahren und 6 Erweiterungen
Schluss machen.
Na ja, also 4 Jahre und 6 Erweiterungen scheint ja schon mal gar nicht so schlecht gewesen
zu sein.
Ist halt die Frage, wahrscheinlich haben sie absolut keine Kohle daraus mitgenommen.
Was halt ein bisschen schade ist, so richtig komplexe Games haben es heute schwer.
Keine weitere Unterstützung mehr teilte Counterplay Games Anfang Januar mit.
Kurzzeit später wurden die Online-Server abgeschaltet.
Selbst eine Marke wie Final Fantasy ist vor einem Flop nicht sicher.
Mobius Final Fantasy erschien 2015 in Japan als Mobile-Titel und ein Jahr später auch
im Rest der Welt.
Das für einen Smartphone-Titel aufwendig produzierte Free-to-Play-RPG war eine Art
Best-of.
Ist das ein Smartphone-Free-to-Play-MMO, wahrscheinlich mit 30 Millionen Microtransactions.
Aber na gut, also das ist, in Japan hätte ich mir eigentlich gedacht, geht der Kram
ab.
Als Krieger des Legs stellte man sich gegen die Finsternis, levelte in runden Basiten
kämpfen und erkundete kleine...
Achso, verstehe.
Das war nur Cutscene, das Spiel sieht überhaupt nicht so aus.
Fichte wurde dabei in mehreren Separaten oder veröffentlichten Kapiteln und Akten
erzählt.
Es gab auch immer wieder verschiedene Crossover-Events mit Bekanntnismen...
Raid Shadow Legends in Final Fantasy Optik.
...Final Fantasy Charakteren.
Zunächst war Mobius auch ein großer Erfolg.
Bis 2017 luden insgesamt über 10 Millionen Fans das Spiel herunter.
Exquisite.
In der letzten Zeit war sogar eine Version für den PC mit besserer Grafik erschienen.
Die hohen Download-Zahlen verwandelten sich aber nicht in eine stabile Community.
Stattdessen probierten viele das Free-to-Play-Spiel einfach aus...
Gut, das liegt dann aber daran, dass das Spiel zackt.
Also es muss ja schon einen Grund haben, dass es 10.000 Leute ausprobieren und keiner hängen
bleibt.
Das kann man dann eigentlich nur auf das Game schieben.
...und ließen es danach links liegen.
Square Enix musste sich Anfang 2020 eingestehen, dass der Aufwand in krasser Schieflage zum
Nutzen stand.
Deswegen wurde nur noch der zweite Anwalt eingestellt und das Spiel wenige Monate später
vom Netz genommen.
Wenn MMOs unter akutem Spielermangel leiden, dann bleiben meistens nur zwei Möglichkeiten.
Das Spiel einstellen oder umkrempeln.
Das Herbestellnis der Studio MadHead entschied sich für Letzteres und vollzog einen ungewöhnlichen
Schritt, nachdem das Online-Action-Rollenspiel nicht als Diablo-Ersatz überzeugen konnte.
Man trennte sich vom Publisher Wargaming und strich den Multiplayer.
Pagan Online wurde zum reinen Singleplayer-Schnetzler Pagan Epic.
Das kann doch nix werden.
Also damit haben sie wahrscheinlich die letzten Fans, die das Game hat verkraulen.
Somit ist Pagan Online zwar Geschichte, doch das Spiel lebt weiter.
Leider wird das auch erstmal das letzte Update für das Spiel gewesen sein.
Das Entwicklerteam kündigte an, dass es in naher Zukunft keine neuen Inhalte für die
Offline-Variante geben wird.
Nur wenn das Interesse seitens der Community wieder steigen würde, wären neue Inhalte
für die Offline-Variante möglich.
Was ist mit der Online-Variante?
Ach gut, die hatten sie ja vorher schon eingestellt.
Einstellig?
Okay, das ist natürlich, ähm, ja.
Moment.
Leute, spinnt mein Prane jetzt oder hatte ich das gerade wirklich doppelt gesagt?
Habt ihr das auch gehört?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt nochmal überprüfen.
Mit derzeit einstelligen Spielerzahlen scheint das aber sehr unwahrscheinlich zu sein.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Spielerzahlen scheint das aber sehr unwahrscheinlich zu sein.
Mit derzeit einstelligen Spielerzahlen scheint das aber sehr unwahrscheinlich zu sein.
Ja, die hat das wirklich zweimal gesagt.
Nein, die hat das wirklich zweimal gesagt.
Ich hab schon gedacht, mein Gehirn leckt, Alter.
Moment, was?
Es sollte Among Us 2 geben?
Wirklich?
Alle Wege zu geringer Nachfrage eingestellt werden mussten.
Im Falle von Among Us 2 liegt der Grund aber tatsächlich in einer zu hohen Nachfrage.
Denn nachdem Teil 1 über Nacht überraschend sämtliche Twitch- und Steam-Charts dominierte,
kündigte das Entwicklerteam relativ zeitnah einen Nachfolger an.
Nach reiflicher Überlegung entschied sich Innerslof aber am Ende dazu, den bisherigen
Plan über Bord zu werfen.
Und das Alte zu verbessern.
Der Wunderperiod ist ursprünglich 2018 ohne Fehlaufsehen erschienen.
Durch Streams auf Twitch schaffte Among Us aber den Durchbruch und löste einen Ansturm
auf die Server aus, der zeitweise selbst GTA Online in den Schatten stellte.
Statt den Hype mit einer Fortsetzung wurden...
Das ist so das Twitch-Game 2020.
Vielleicht neben Fall Guys, wobei Fall Guys mittlerweile total, das ist einfach verschwunden
irgendwie.
Was waren dann so noch so riesen Twitch-Games?
Also mir fällt jetzt Among Us, Fall Guys, was hatten sie 2020 denn sonst noch so?
Rust?
Tatsächlich stimmt, Rust ist wieder voll beliebt, ich weiß gar nicht warum.
Ne, Valorant nicht.
Ne, ich mein jetzt was halt so aus dem Nichts gehypt war, ne Auto-Battler waren ganz schnell
weg, aber echt, Schach ohne Scheiße, Schach!
Schach war der richtige Hype auf Twitch zwischenzeitlich 2020.
Richtig echtes Schach.
Da hab ich mich auch gefragt, wie kommt's auf einmal?
Mittlerweile nicht so, aber es gucken immer noch viele.
So richtig oldschool Schach.
Minecraft, ja Minecraft immer.
Die Inhalte, die für Teil 2 geplant waren, sollen jetzt sukzessive für Among Us umgesetzt
werden.
Dazu gehört eine bessere Technik, ein ausgebautes Account-System, Freundeslisten und komplett
neue Level, die mehr Möglichkeiten zum Lügen und Betrügen bieten.
Dass es erstmal kein Among Us 2 geben wird, ist für die Fans also keine traurige Nachricht.
Auf der E3 2019 stellte Bethesda ein neues Commander Keen für iOS und Android vor.
Mit Elder Scrolls Blades und Fallout Shelter hatte das Unternehmen in der Vergangenheit
mit solchen Moden...
Hat wirklich irgendjemand gesagt, ich will jetzt 2020 neues Commander Keen?
...Mobile-Umsetzung schon gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Also warum nicht auch den Platforming-Klassiker Commander Keen probieren?
Tja, die Ankündigung an der Neuauflage kam bei Fans eher so mittelgut an.
What the fuck?
Das hat ja mit dem Original mal absolut gar nichts mehr zu tun.
Na gut, es ist halt ein stumpfes Mobile-Game geworden.
Das erste Trailer erinnerte nur entfernt an das Original.
Inhaltlich schien alles mehr in Richtung Samstagmorgen-Kartoon zu gehen und spielerisch
waren jetzt...
Es ist halt...
Es ist halt einfach ein dummes Mobile-Game jetzt.
...rundenbasierte Kämpfe angesagt und keine Side-Scrolling-Herausforderungen.
Auch Bethesda scheint...
Okay, man hat...
Wie dieses Spiel entstanden, ist ganz einfach.
Die haben gesagt, wir brauchen ein neues Mobile-Game.
Ja, okay, wie nennen wir es, was machen wir?
Ah, Moment.
Dann ist irgendein Typ hingegangen, hat den Katalog an Patenten und Namensrechten rausgeholt
und haben gesagt, ah, guck mal, wir haben die Rechte für Commander Keen.
Kennt das noch irgendjemand?
Dann haben sie alle gesagt, haha, Lul, Boomer Game und dann haben sie dann so ein komisches
Ding rausgemacht.
...zu haben.
Aber anstatt das Spiel zu überarbeiten, wurde es mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit einfach
eingestellt.
Von offizieller Seite hat man nämlich schon lange nichts mehr von Commander Keen gehört.
Ja, juckt ja auch keinen.
Zudem wurden alle Erinnerungen auf Entwickler-Webseiten entfernt und auch die offizielle Webseite
des Spiels selbst wurde deaktiviert.
Alle Hinweise deuten darauf hin, dass Commander Keen in dieser Form erstmal nicht wieder zurückkehren
wird.
Das ist nicht prozentig bestätigt, ist dies aber noch nicht.
Kommen wir jetzt zu den kürzlich bekannt gewordenen Spielen, die schon vor langer
Zeit eingestellt wurden, aber jetzt erst auftauchten.
Dazu gehört eine vorlagengetreue Umsetzung der Herr-der-Ringe-Film-Trilogie von den Lego-Spezialisten
von Travellers.
Das sieht ja sogar relativ filmmäßig aus.
Mit der Vorproduktion der Hobbit-Verfilmungen arbeitet das Team ein halbes Jahr lang in
einer aufwendigen Tech-Demo, die das Filmstudio überzeugen sollte, das komplette Spiel zu
finanzieren.
Statt der üblichen Lego-Formel wollte Travellers Tales aber eng an Peter Jacksons Version
von Mittelerde bleiben.
Dafür gab das Team über eine Million US-Dollar aus.
Und der Publisher hat dann gesagt, um keiner Wollz haben.
...Charaktere, die das Gameplay teils drastisch geändert hätten.
Studio-Mitgründer John Burton zeigte vor ein paar Monaten sogar echtes Gameplay aus
dem eingestellten Projekt.
Als Frodo Beutlin wäre man an Orks vorbeigeschlichen und hätte als Gandalf gegen den Balrog gekämpft.
Ich hoffe, die hätten den passenden Soundtrack dabei gehabt.
Also ohne das geht's ja nicht.
Ohne Gandalf Sachskei geht's nicht.
Also das muss auf jeden Fall in das, also wenn das nicht im Hauptmenü läuft, dann weiß
ich auch nicht.
Warte mal, ich hab's mal geschafft, ich hab's mal geschafft den Original, äh, Epic Sachskei,
also den Typ, ich hab das mal wirklich geschafft acht Stunden am Stück zu hören.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie ich das geschafft hab, aber danach, dann, das ist
ungefähr so, wie wenn du Ayaya intensifies zehn Stunden hörst oder so.
Du bist, du bist matt im Kopf.
Nicht auf der Arbeit daheim, im Hintergrund hat's das Laufen.
Saffran hat mal im Stream Ayaya-Song zehn Stunden gehört, ja so, so gehört sich's ja
auch.
Ich überleg grad, warum, warum hab ich, ich hab, also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
ich hab das Ding wirklich acht, sieben, acht, neun Stunden irgendwie lang gehört.
Ich überleg grad, warum ich das, das hatte irgendeinen, das hatte irgendeinen, irgendeinen
Grund.
Ah, ich weiß wieder warum, ähm, ich war, jetzt, jetzt kann ich mich wieder dran erinnern,
warum ich den Mist acht Stunden am Stück laufen hatte.
Ich war beim HNO-Arzt, am, äh, also morgens, ja, und wenn man was am Ohr gemacht kriegt,
dann ist das manchmal so, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, so wenn ihr, wenn ihr irgendwie
so ausgespült kriegt oder irgendwas, so übelst ekliges Zeug, ja, und, ähm, je nachdem,
wie sehr der da an euch rumgebastelt hat, habt ihr den ganzen Tag oder vielleicht auch zwei,
drei Tage, äh, Piepsen, Rauschen, Brummen, sonst was im Ohr.
Und ich glaube, das war ein Tag, wo ich da gewesen bin beim Doktor, und da hab ich einfach
acht Stunden gehört, dass mich das Brummen im Ohr nicht genervt hat.
Weil das ist so ein Ding, wenn man, wenn man irgendwie Brummen im Ohr hat, das Beste, was
man machen kann, ist entweder Regen-Sounds hören oder, ähm, Musik, die so wellenmäßig
ist, so wie das hier, dann hört man das nicht mehr, aber, aber dann irgendwann abends war
wieder gut und ich konnte es ausmachen, ich, jetzt, jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder, exzellent.
So, okay, genug, gucken wir das Video weiter.
Wie gesagt, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es ein Herr-der-Ringe-Game geben soll, es gibt
meiner Meinung nach eh viel zu wenig Herr-der-Ringe-Kram, also, meiner Ansicht nach, ja, hups, äh, Chat,
ich hab euch aus Versehen geschlossen.
Einfach Ohr abschalten, ja, das ist so wie, wie wenn du in einem AMO sagst, oder in einem
Shooter-Zeit einfach nicht sterben, Feifett, ja, ähm, es gibt eh, finde ich, viel zu
wenig Herr-der-Ringe-Zeit in letzter Zeit, gut, das ist halt, die Hobby-Trilogie hat
gesagt, ja, er hat ein paar coole Sachen gehabt, beispielsweise die Szene mit, mit Bilbo und
dem Drache, da in diesem Gold-Lager, äh, nicht Gold-Lager, in diesem, äh, Berg mit,
mit Gold und so, Schatz-Dingskammer, zwar schon cool, aber der Rest war halt übelst
kacke, also hat mir auch nicht gefallen, man hat auch gemerkt, dass sie die Filme auseinander
geschnitten haben, von zwei Filmen zu, äh, irgendwie random auseinander gereiteten drei
Filmen, und dazwischen das mit CGI aufgefüllt haben, aber die originale Herr-der-Ringe-Trilogie
war echt nice, und meiner Meinung nach gibt's da viel zu wenig, für, weil es gibt immer
noch, gerade, gerade die Boomer in meinem Alter, die, äh, so, quasi, so, gerade in
dem Alter waren, wo sie sowas geil fanden, wo es Herr-der-Ringe im Kino gab, und, ähm,
die könnte man viel mehr bedienen, also das sollte, das sollte man unbedingt mehr machen,
es gibt ab und zu mal ein Game und so, aber da könnte man viel mehr, viel mehr machen.
So, gucken wir mal weiter, das Einzige was aktuell gemolken wird als fuck ist halt Star
Wars, und es juckt mich halt persönlich gar nicht, Star Trek melken sie auch mit immer
schlechteren Sachen, äh, was ist denn sonst noch so voll, was, was wird denn sonst noch
so, eigentlich wird alles mehr oder weniger gemolken, oh, wisst ihr was das Allerschlimmste
ist, was einfach nicht aufhört, was einfach nicht aufhört, wo es immer wieder neue Sachen
gibt, das ist, ähm, ach fuck, wie heißt diese Zombie-Serie, Marvel wird gemolken, ja, wobei,
da geht das Zeug, geht ja irgendwie noch, aber diese Monster-Serie, fuck, ich hab grad
vergessen, wie heißt denn das, die bekannteste Monster-Serie überhaupt, nicht Monster, Zombie,
Zombie-Serie meine ich, Zombie-Serie, äh, Walking Dead meine ich, genau, Walking Dead,
ey, Walking Dead das wird gemolken bis zum geht nicht mehr, das ist so ein Ding, da
hätten sie nach drei Staffeln einfach aufhören sollen, und mittlerweile ist glaub ich die
Main-Serie fertig oder so, ich weiß, ich hab das gar nicht mehr verfolgt, die Main-Serie
irgendwie fertig, nach frag mich nicht, sieben Staffeln oder so, und jetzt gibt's 30 Milliarden
Spin-Offs, die noch schlechter sind, und die Original-Serie war schon schlecht, ja, egal,
gucken wir mal weiter, also Walking Dead wird auch gemolken bis zum geht nicht mehr, ja,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich weil es zu viele Lizenzkosten kostet, ja, ja, ja, ja,
das ist echt, der ist schlecht aus, sieht aus wie PS1-Game, kpz2, ja, genau, so sieht
es auch aus, sieht auch aus wie 2003, Gamecube oder so, kpz1, kpz2, kpz1, kpz2, kpz1, kpz1,
kpz2, kpz1, kpz1, kpz2, kpz1, kpz1, kpz1, kpz1, kpz1, kpz1, kpz1, kpz1, kpz1, kpz2,
Oder so mit Ben Affleck erscheinen die arbeitend daran liefen bereits seit über einem jahr
Doch streitigkeiten im hintergrund geil geil das liefen über einem jahr 2000 also spricht die haben das 2002 entwickelt ja das ist natürlich
essentiell im jahr 2020 zu wissen
Prototyp vorhanden ist als blinder anwalt und hätte ich das jetzt nicht gewusst
Hätten wir in dem spiel hets kitchen erkundet der new yorker stadtteil war aber keine richtige open world sondern übersichtlicher
hets kitchen und wo ist gone ramsey
Busy
Schweiß neben prüggelein zu fuß springt der rote teufel in prototypen über dächer und sauß dank eines grind systems an kabeln stangen und rohren entlang
Okay, das hätte ich auch damals nicht gespielt
Das hätte ich auch damals nicht so spiel also
Generell superhelden games ist nicht so meins wobei das das letzte spider-man auf der playstation wohl ziemlich gut sein sollte
Schreiber sollte auch Daredevil ein ähnliches System spendieren kommen, da darfst du Frauen
schlagen was ist da los? Spiel ist instant zensiert heute, ich glaube es geht los, selbst
wenn das im Comic Look und in Games ist, das geht ja gar nicht. Neben dem Superhelden persönlich
hätte man im finalen Produkt auch andere Daredevil Charaktere wie Elektra oder Bullseye spielen
können. In den Spiele-Dateien fanden Fans zudem Hinweise darauf, dass auch Black Widow
als Charakter und Mentor-Figur vorgekommen wäre. Am Ende wurde aus den ambitionierten
Plänen aber nichts. Die Entwickler Sony und Marvel konnten sich einfach nicht auf ein
Spiel spielen. Stimmt, Arkham Asylum ist wirklich cool gewesen. Das ist eines der wenigen Superhelden
Games was ich gespielt habe. Und auch gar nicht wegen Batman, ehrlich gesagt ich hätte
es wahrscheinlich auch anders gespielt wenn es nicht Batman gewesen wäre. Und so wartet
Daredevil noch heute auf seinen ersten großen Videospiel-Auftritt. Zum 60-jährigen Firmenjubiläum
hat Sega dieses Jahr etwas besonders aus den Archiven geholt. Einen gescheiterten Golden
X Prototypen der als Demo kostenlos auf Steam veröffentlicht wurde. Das sieht auch richtig
generic und schlecht aus. Und Sena plante das Unternehmen mehrere Oldies wie Streets of
Rage, Altered Beast und eben auch Golden X. Boah sieht das langweilig aus. Sega Australien
sollte sich um die Umgebung... Also jetzt mal ernsthaft, also viel langweiliger kann
ja ein Gamecom aussehen. Das sieht aus als hätte jemand Unity genommen, ein paar Models
aus dem Asset Store reingezogen, ein fertiges Level aus dem Asset Store und sagt auf geht's.
2013 schloss jedoch die Firma ihre Forten und der Prototyp schaffte nie den Sprung zu
einem vollwertigen Spiel. Kurz nach der Veröffentlichung der Demo meldete sich aber Tim Dawson, einer
der damals beteiligten Entwickler, über Twitter zu Wort und zeichnet ein etwas anderes Bild.
Laut Dawson hätte sich Sega im Vorfeld nicht bei ihm gemeldet. Er war selbst über den
Release des Prototypen überrascht, schreibt er weiter. Seine Zeit bei Sega hat er in keiner
besonders guten Erinnerung. Die Golden X Demo entstand unter enormem Druck und extrem vielen
Überstunden, die er und sein Team... Okay das ist natürlich mies, aber ich finde das
sieht doch echt langweilig aus....management zu überzeugen. Letztendlich soll die Führungsebene
aber die Qualität des Spiels nicht erkannt haben und teils widersprüchlich gehandelt
haben. Ja ich erkenne ehrlich gesagt die Qualität der Demo jetzt auch nicht. Dawson stand deswegen
der Veröffentlichung der Demo sehr kritisch gegenüber. Sega hat sich mittlerweile beim
Entwickler und seinem Team entschuldigt und die Steam Beschreibung nach seinem Feedback
überarbeitet. Wer will kann heute noch die Demo herunterladen und sich selbst einen Eindruck
von dem gescheiterten Projekt verschaffen. Zum Abschluss kommen wir nochmal zu einem
Spiel zurück das 2020 veröffentlicht... Stimmt! Der Titel sagt mir noch irgendwas....und dann
sofort abgestürzt ist. Nämlich Disintegration. Der Titel sagt mir noch irgendwas. Mixed-Ego-Shooter
und Echtzeit-Taktik bei dem er ein Hover-Fahrzeug über den Schlachtfeld an der Zukunft steuert,
ballert und gleichzeitig noch einen kleinen Trupp Bodeneinheiten... Jajajaja Moment das
kenne ich. Das kommt mir bekannt vor. Was war denn damit? Das habe ich überhaupt nicht
mal verfolgt. Das kommt mir irgendwie noch bekannt vor. Ja genau, genau, genau. Da kann
ich mich doch dran erinnern an die Demo. Oder halt an die Präsentation. Ha! Okay das war
nicht so erfolgreich. Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein
Destiny. Oder? Also es sieht schon ein bisschen aus wie Destiny. Schade drum. Aber vielleicht
hat ja ein Publisher trotzdem das Potential erkannt, dass in der noch jungen Firma hinter
Disintegration steckt und gibt dem Team eine zweite Chance. In diesem Jahr gehört das Spiel
von V1 Interactive genau wie die anderen Hittler auf dieser Liste aber zu den Verlierern,
die 2020 nicht überlebt haben. Aber ist das überhaupt so traurig? Weint ihr einen dieser
Spiele wirklich hinterher? Ehrlich zu sein. Schreibt es uns. Ja Crucible. Ehrlich gesagt
nicht. Nicht wirklich. Die einzigen für die ich schade finde ist Duelist. Aber ansonsten
nicht wirklich. Also für Duelist finde ich schade. Das habe ich ja am Rande mal ab und
zu immer so mitbekommen, dass es im Sale war und die dachte eigentlich das kommt auch ganz
gut an. Aber ist es anscheinend nicht. Mal gucken ob uns YouTube noch irgendwas gescheites
empfiehlt. Amazon Trash Game. Ja was Crucible. Ja aber richtig. Pepe Jam. Alles klar. Top
Games 2020. Tja da hätte ich erstmal 2020 bisschen was spielen müssen. Komm das müssen
wir jetzt noch schnell gucken. Mich interessiert wirklich was die sagen. Also es ist auf jeden
Fall The Last Of Us 2 dabei. Gehe ich mal von aus. Wobei das von Fans halt richtig gehadet
wurde. Half Life Alex ist auf jeden Fall dabei. Was gab es denn alles? Ich habe schon wieder
voll voll verdrängt. Was hat man eigentlich alles? Warum gibt es das hier? The fuck? Animal
Crossing war auch groß. Komm wir gucken einfach mal das Video. Wir können einfach. Ah ok Leute
wir müssen das Video nicht gucken. Dank YouTube Vorschau. Doom hatten wir noch. Also das ist
LOL. Was haben wir? Süß und geruhsam. Das ist Animal Crossing. Dann haben wir The Last
Of Us 2. Dann haben wir was ist das? Spelunky oder sowas. Das weiß man wahrscheinlich gar
nicht. Spelunky ausspricht. Der Flight Simulator ok. Pains Champ. Das ist doch auch ein Game
was nur punkten kann weil es die offiziellen Lizenzen hat oder? Äh ist das Mafia Remake?
Ne ach ne das ist Jakuza oder wie man das ausspricht. Dann haben wir was ist das?
Ah Crusader Kings ist das oder? Gewesen. Oder? Ja Crusader Kings war das. Daher bin
ich jetzt drauf gekommen. Was haben wir hier? Ist das Dragon Quest? Axeno Play Chronicles
alles klar. Ach stimmt das ist das Remake für die Switch? Genau. Demon's Souls Remake
ok. Persona. Was haben wir sonst noch? Ich hab keinen Plastenschimmer. Hades ist das?
Das ist Ori 2. Dann haben wir ok jetzt ist das Dragon Quest. Exquisite. Und Half Life.
Ja kann man so sehen. Manchmal ist dieses YouTube Chapter Feature echt gut. Man muss
das Video gar nicht gucken und weiß schon was abgeht. Holst du dir Steam VR? Ne ich
hab keine VR Brille und ich sehs auch nicht allen für ein Game was zu kaufen. Auf der
anderen Seite was gibt's denn für gute VR Games? Ist das neue Half Life? Alien Isolation
VR soll richtig MonkaS mäßig sein. Ja was gibt's denn sonst noch für gute VR Chat?
VR Chat? Naja was gibt's für gute Hitman VR? Ah Resident Evil genau. Ja das ist auch
cool. Was ist eigentlich auf Playstation VR geworden? Leute was kauft man sich wenn
man sich eine kaufen will? Was kauft man sich aktuell für ein 3D Brillen? Was ist da gerade
angesagt? Was kostet das? Oder was gibt's da generell was gerade gut ist? HTC Vive?
Ne oder die HTC Vive ist glaub ich voll out. Glaub das nicht mehr angesagt. Oculus Quest.
Was Facebook Account? Warum? Ok VR Brille. Guck mal was da kommt wenn ich danach such.
Ah ja. Ah exellent. Die ist bestimmt gut Leute. Die ist bestimmt richtig gut. Desetech
V5 VR Classes. Die ist bestimmt richtig next level shit. Gibt's Resident Evil 7 VR am PC?
Ich glaub schon. Also Resident Evil gibt's am PC. Ich weiß aber nicht ob's das VR am
PC gibt. Jemenrennen 3D. Das ist ja bitte immer besser hier. Nur vom feinsten was es
hier gibt bei Amazon. VR Primus. Alles klar. Bestell bei Wish. Stimmt. Die Font for Valve
gibt's ja auch was. Aber die gibt's doch natürlich bei Amazon. Es gibt ein AMVR Facial Interface
Bracket. Ok das ist im Prinzip ein Gestell wo man vorne ein Handy rein macht oder so.
Ne. Aber ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß nicht ob's da irgendwas gutes gibt falls ich mir kaufe.
Ne ich kauf mir keins. Weil ich seh's nicht ein 500 Euro auszugeben für 2-3 Games. Wenn
ich 500 Euro ausgeben will für 2-3 Games. Da kann ich mir auch ne Playstation 5 kaufen
oder ne Xbox S. Series X. S wie auch immer es jetzt genau heißt. Da spiel ich auch maximal
2-3 Games. Und kann 3-400 Euro 500 Euro ausgeben. Ok YouTube schlägt nix Gescheites vor. Was
ist das denn? 12 Stunden Neujahrs Ansprache. Jetzt übertreib's halt nicht. Welt. Mal gucken
ob die die Kommentare wieder deaktiviert haben. Ich will das nicht gucken. Ich will nur gucken.
So geil. Da muss man sagen das muss man den Amis echt mal zugute halten ne. Unter Corona
Videos und aktuellen politischen Dinge in den USA oder so. Da wird auch extrem rumgeflamt.
Aber eins muss man den Amis echt mal zugute halten. Die schalten nie Comments ab. Da rennen
auch so viele verrückte Leute rum von allen Seiten. Aber die schalten nie die Comments
ab. Und hier in deutschen Videos sind total viele Comments abgeschaltet. Ah ok den gibt's
hier noch. Anleitung zu ungenau. Kabel steckt im Abfest. Also manche Memesachen sind schon
immer lustig weil die so abgenutzt sind. Zeigt bisher kaum. Naja gut man muss ja mal
Fairness halber sagen. Die haben das ja hoffentlich ordentlich getestet und manche Nebenwirkungen
sind halt auch nicht unbedingt erst nach einer Woche am Start. Haben wir denn in Deutschland
die gleiche. Letztendlich ist das worauf es ankommt. Erstens YouTube in dem Fall. Wenn
die da Meinung sind Sachen gehen nicht dann gehen sie nicht weil es halt immer noch YouTube.
Und ich hab zumindest den Eindruck. Ich weiß nicht ob die Gesetzeslage unterschiedlich
ist. Kenn ich mich nicht aus. Aber ich hab zumindest den Eindruck dass wir generell
gerne einfach lieber die. Also in Deutschland lieber die Kommentarfunktion abschalten als
sich mit der unliebsamen Sachen auseinanderzusetzen. Ich mein klar da ist auch viel Scheiß dabei.
Ich mein ich weiß es ja selbst und ich hab noch eine gute YouTube Comments Sektion aber
auch bei mir ist viel Scheiß dabei. Also was können wir uns nächstes angucken. Der Auer
sagt was zu Ende 2020 das können wir uns angucken. Wir können uns auf Battlefield 4 Top Plays
angucken. Wir können uns das. Das habe ich schon gesehen. Das ist echt Paynes Champ.
Das ist lustig. Das ist echt richtig Paynes Champ. Das ist typisch deutscher Amts Amts
Crap. Das ist Volker Krüger ehemaliger Theater Direktor aus Glauchau. Das rechts neben ihm
ist sein. Also also die die die Sprecher triggern mich teilweise ja schon ein bisschen. Das
rechts neben ihm ist sein Auto und das da ganz rechts ist sein Auto Kennzeichen. Volker
Krüger ist eine Gefahr aber das ist echt gut. Ich hab das. Das habe ich schon mal geguckt.
Deutschlands Schuld daran ist dieses Kennzeichen. Also wer da nicht erkennt dass das dass das
Insel Nazi ab also ich mein GCRT 28 dann das ist ja sowas sowas vor Nazi das Nummernschild
der weiß sofort schein. Seit 15 Jahren habe ich das Nummernschild. Melde das immer im
Sommer ab im Winter wieder an. Kein Problem lasst das reservieren beim Landratsamt und
diesmal wurde mir gesagt das bekomme ich nicht wieder. Das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Dabei ist es doch extrem einfach zu verstehen wer hier recht hat. Wir haben die Palette
der Kennzeichen oder wenn ich die Amtsfrau schon sehe Zahlen die bestimmte Kombination
nationalsozialistisches Gedankengut verbreitet haben wir einfach reduziert und das Kennzeichen
von Volker Krüger lässt sich eindeutig in die rechte Ecke stellen. Ganz normales solides
Nummernschild was seit 15 Jahren existiert und keinerlei negative Ausstrahlung. Ich kann
mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern. Ich glaube die stören sich daran dass er 28 im
Nummernschild hat oder so. Total random. Warum auch immer 28. Gucken sie sich das doch mal
ganz genau an ist doch klar was hier Nazi Gedankengut ist. Hoppla was ist es denn jetzt
genau. Die 28 ist es. Die 28 Sauerei. Moment. Jetzt fragen sie mich bitte nicht genau was
genau die 28 heißt. Könnten wir recherchieren und nachgucken. Ja das wäre ja nicht schlecht
wenn man es ablehnt zu wissen warum oder. Gucken sie doch mal. Noch 28 Sekunden dann
finden sie es doch bestimmt raus. Jetzt sind wir da. Die 28 steht auf Deutsch für Blut
und Ehre und. Was. Wie um alles in der Welt kommt man von 28 auf Blut und Ehre. Blut und
Ehre ist eine. Also ich meine 8 8 und H. Okay. Aber aber 2. Rechtsextremistische Organisation.
Und was hat die 28 damit zu tun. Die Amtsfrau ist ja geil. Die tut wenigstens
nicht so als müsste. Es ist so genau das ist ohne Scheiß. Das ist echt eines der Probleme
die wir haben was amtmäßig angeht. Egal ob das sinn sinnvoll ist irgendwie mit Sinn
und Verstand wenn das so ist dann ist das so. Das ist einfach so. So nämlich die 2 steht
auf Deutsch für das B im Alphabet. Die 8 für das H. Ach so. Ach du Scheiße wer kommt
denn auf sowas. Was machen denn die Leute die irgendwie mal 2028 geboren werden. Oder
überlegt euch mal es gibt Leute die sind 1988 geboren. Also was ist das denn der Nazi
Jahrgang oder wie. Für das H ergibt B und H steht für Blut und Ehre. So löst der Landkreis
Zwickau das Nazi Problem. Toll finden auch Antirechts Aktivisten. Der Rechtsextremismus
wird kein deutsch weniger. Doch sollte man nur nicht. Die 14 die 18 die 28 und die 88
also alles mit 8 8 und 4. 14 14 ist das die Hälfte ist das die Hälfte von 28 ist quasi
ist das dann. Was ist in der vierte Buchstabe A B C D A und D. A und D. Active Directory
ok das kann ich verstehen dass das verboten ist. Warum jetzt die 14. Die Amtsfrau 0 oder
was ist Adi Adolf Dittler oder was soll Adi bedeuten. Fragen Sie die Amtsfrau ist schon
geil. Die tut wenigstens nicht so als wüsste. Das ist so feil es ist echt so so ohne Sinn
und Verstand aller. Kurzweil können wir nachher noch gucken. Ich will nicht so viel am Stück.
Oh Leute ich habe den Chat aus Versehen zugemacht. Jetzt Chat wo seid ihr. Der Chat ist weg. Jetzt
ist der Chat wieder da exquisite. Einfach kann ich einfach der Chat weggehen Browser was
ist denn hier los. Ja ich stelle mir vor wenn man am 2.8. geboren wurde. Alter Leute da
bin ich ja knapp vorbei. Ich habe ja im August Geburtstag. Oh man. Das Schlimme ist umso
mehr dieser Zahlen du hast oder Zahlen und Buchstaben und umso mehr hast du Kombinationen
davon das heißt irgendwann ist die Hälfte der Nummernschilde nicht mal gültig. Genau
stell dir mal vor in Hamburg hätte eine H H 88. Ach du Scheiße das ist bestimmt nicht
erlaubt. Das bestimmt nicht erlaubt. Das ist dann schon zu offensichtlich. Hast du schon
das Video von Electro Boom und Linus gesehen. Ja fand ich langweilig. Weiß nicht. Also
ich gucke Linus gucke ich letzter Zeit wenig. Electro Boom gucke ich relativ häufig. Aber
das Kombinations Video fand ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig spannend. Realtime Ray Tracing
und Super Nintendo exzellent. Das läuft das läuft ja sogar richtig gut. Das läuft ja
das läuft ja flüssiger als Star Fox. Und sieht besser aus als Star Fox. Läuft es
auf dem echten NES nie oder. Das läuft auf einem SNES Expansion Chip. Das läuft nicht
wirklich auf dem NES auf dem SNES. Das ist ein extra Chip. Ok ja ja das war es anderes.
Aber ich meine für Super Nintendo sind das Maximum Progress Graphics. Oh ist doch nicht
schlecht. Vor allem solange das nicht vorgespult ist. Ja ja das stimmt schon klar im SNES hatten
die bei der meisten der großen Games Zusatzchips. Hast du 100 Gigabit S an der Switches von
Linus gesehen? Nö. Ich glaube nicht das das so ein wahnsinniger Gewinn ist das Video anzugucken.
Ich habe wie gesagt ich gucke in letzter Zeit Linus wenig. Ich finde es zum größten Teil
langweilig. Battlefield 4 Toplet. Komm wir gucken jetzt mal eine Runde. Battlefield 4
Excellent. Oder zeichne mal hier. Was macht er denn mit 100GBE? Ja warum nicht? Ach vor
zwei Jahren ist das schon ok. Ja aber das ist ja nichts besonderes in dem Sinn. Also
kommt alles auf die Technik und vor allem die Kabellänge an wenn es Kupfer sein soll.
Das weiß ich nicht ganz so well. Der Anti-Web-Video-Preis. Und Apo-Retch dachte er hat sein Channel geklost.
Gibt es den noch? Gibt es den noch? What the fuck? Warum hat er nur drei Videos? Warum
hat er nur drei Videos? Ich blick nicht mal durch. Es interessiert mich auch auf YouTube
Deutschland gar nicht. Ist mir egal. Der Auer ist umgezogen ja. Mal den Beef kurz mitgenommen.
Im Zweifelsfall. Ich habe keine Ahnung was da geht. Wahrscheinlich sogar noch Calculated
Beef. Nach dem Motto. Das beste was man machen kann wenn man auf YouTube wieder im Gespräch
sein will ist Beef anfangen. Also eigentlich wenn ich mir vornehmen würde Max 2021 machst
so richtig viel YouTube. Da würde ich erstmal alle größeren Channels auf YouTube über
Twitter und in den Comments erstmal flamen. In der Hoffnung oder am besten auch noch
irgendwelche Exposed Videos oder sowas machen. Und dann hoffen dass die drauf reacten. Und
dann hoffen dass die drauf reacten und dann kommen die alle zu mir und flamen mich. Aber
wenn sie mich flamen da bleiben genug Leute hängen. Aber so Content mache ich ja nicht
also bin ich da nicht der richtige Typ für. Ich habe nicht gerne Beef mit Leuten. Vor
allem nicht gerne Beef mit Leuten die mir eigentlich voll egal sind und mich überhaupt
nicht interessieren. Hast du schon die neuen C++ Updates durchgelesen? Ja. Die haben jetzt
die 15. Bedeutung für Spitze Klammer und eckige Klammer eingeführt. 14 Bedeutung. Doppeldeutsche
Bedeutung war noch nicht genug. Jetzt brauchen wir eine 15. Mach einen Disstrack. Ahja. Das
wollte ich schon immer mal machen. Ich wollte schon immer mal so einen schlechten Autotune
Hip Hop Disstrack aufnehmen. Wer nicht ich wäre dann. Richtig Haftbefehl Style. Gürtelstraße
Louis Vuitton Store. Zahl die Kollektion bar Fick auf Sponsor reicht da nur. Stylo sagt
was Apo hat eine Frau sexuell beläscht und Mimmi hat das aufgelegt. Ist das wirklich
so? Weil das ist so ein Thema da muss man heute echt ein bisschen vorsichtig sein. Da
wird denke ich auch mal ganz gerne ein bisschen zu schnell geschossen ohne zu gucken ob das
echt so ist. Apo hat versucht sich rauszureden na gut das ist nichts neues. Und dann wurde
er angezeigt. Dann hat er alle Videos gelöscht. Aha. Okay. Interessiert mich nicht. Ist mir
sowas von wurscht. Die können alle machen was wollen. Es geht mir am Arsch vorbei was
auf YouTube Deutschland passiert. Es ist eigentlich die Zeit gar nicht wert sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Falls du noch was zum Reaktion brauchst. Was soll ich darauf reaktieren. Haben sie gestern
mal die gebollert. Wie gesagt 2 3 Raketen oder so ein bisschen. Aber es war nichts was
man auch daran gesehen hat. Die Katze ist ganz entspannt rumgestellt durch die Wohnung. Die
ist null null interessiert. Wir gucken jetzt. Komm wir gucken eine Runde. Battlefield Battlefield
Plays. Aber ist die. Auflösung so schlecht von dem. Oder mein Video Auflösung. Ah ne
ne die Auflösung von dem Kerl ist so schlecht. Verstehe. Ach es ist Metro 2020. Der hat
einen guten Namen. Das sehe ich auch so. Guck mal wie der heißt. Stimmt die neue Metro Version
hat ja sogar ein Fahrstuhl. Die neue Metro Version hat ein Fahrstuhl und ein Gang links
außen. Ich erinnere mich dunkel. Das ist so was was die Venice an Leash Leute auch mal
machen könnten. Metro einfach ein bisschen besser spielbar machen. Weil Metro ist an
sich eine coole Close Quarter Map. Aber Metro ist halt so ein so ein. Wir kämpfen gerade
bei 64 Mann. Wir kämpfen hinter dem Headclip Spot und und und alles was um die Ecke kommt.
Get Shrecked. Too easy. Könnte Venice. Die könnten das mit Sicherheit als Mod einbauen
mit dem Fahrstuhl. Es muss ja kein Fahrstuhl sein. Sie können einfach in den Gang machen
oder so. Ich überlege gerade ob ich nicht den Map Editor runterladen sollte und versuchen
sollte Metro spielbarer zu machen. Ich glaube das probiere ich mal aus. Das muss ich mal
ausprobieren. Ich lade mir den Map Editor runter und gucke mal ob wir Metro irgendwie
besser spielbar machen können. Moment. Das ist Battlefield 3. Das ist Battlefield 3.
Ach Moment. Er erklärt da gerade warum er einen Battlefield 3 Clip hat. Ich habe
ihn jetzt gerade nicht zugehört. Weil er sagt immer das gleiche. Deswegen habe ich
auch nicht so laut gestellt. Nice. Ich gucke mir eh lieber Battlefield 3 Clip an. Ich gucke
mir eh lieber Battlefield 3 Clips an. Erstmal eine Runde M16 sprengen. Soll ich auch mal
einen Top Play einsenden? Wir hatten bestimmt ein paar Sachen und Stream die nice waren.
35 Minuten ist vielleicht für so ein Top Play ein bisschen lang.
Also die werden auch krass weggesprecht die Jungs hier gerade. Genau schickt den Streamer
ein. Lasst ihn sich selbst die Top Plays raussuchen. Gute Idee. Wird bestimmt gut funktionieren.
Was ist das für ein Foff? Der kann ja fast auf seinen Bobbes gucken bei dem Foff. Der
trifft jetzt. Pass auf der trifft jetzt den Chopper. Ja es war klar. Es war klar dass
der random den Chopper trifft und nicht hinguckt. Und hier ist er stehen geblieben. Hier ist
er stehen geblieben. Hier siehst du richtig so. Und jetzt denkt er ist das ein cooler Clip
zum einschicken? Ist das ein cooler Clip zum einschicken? Ja das ist ein cooler Clip
zum einschicken und macht Shadowplay Aufnahme. Deswegen bleibt er stehen. Muss erstmal den
Hotkey dafür suchen. Schreckt. Schön weg A.E.C.A.T.
Oh das ist ein Deutscher. Das ist ein Deutscher. Die erste Hilfe ist unter dir. Nimm. Gut.
Ich glaube nicht dass das ein Medic im Einsatz normalerweise so sagen würde. Ich kann es
mir so richtig vorstellen. Einer angeschossen wirft den Packing und sagt die erste Hilfe
ist unter dir. Nimm. Heutzutage würden sie sagen Digga mach dir verbannt rum.
Oh die werden schon hart geschreckt die Leute. Die machen es aber auch durf. Die kommen
einfach einzeln von total offenen Posis an gerannt. Valar hier verbannt. Ehrenmann ich
küsse deine Augen. Genau. Ja so wird das heute jemand sagen. Hier kommt das Medikit
Kumpel. Ok das ist vielleicht Sache die könnte vielleicht noch jemand sagen. Bäm. Oh RPG
und direkt Kick. Massive. War da gerade jemand aus dem Stream. Wartet mal kurz. Der Typ
im Haus. Ah ne Fogo 2000 nicht Florian 2000. Florian 2000 haben wir nämlich manchmal im
Stream. Es ist Fogo 2000. Eww. Gibt es die Waffe nicht auch in Warzone. Die ist total
kacke. Ja Force Champ. Weggesprayed sehr gut. Eins muss man sagen daran erkennst du
der kennt die Map. Der kennt die Map das ist immer klar. Hätte Battlefield 4 nur gute
Flashmaps. Die sind brauchbar aber nichts im Vergleich zu BC 1 2 und Battlefield 3. Schreckt.
Ok ok. Nur mal dass ich jetzt die Logik von dem Kommentator verstehe. Das Video nennt
sich Battlefield 4 Top Plays. Das heißt es ist in dem Video drinne was eigentlich schon
bedeutet es ist ein Top Play. Aber wenn er den Clip kommentiert sagt er es ist eigentlich
doch kein Top Play. Was? Das ist die Leute Leute ihr kennen euch damit. Das ist die Pickup
Sniper oder? Das ist nichts was man auslöst die Pickup Sniper glaubt ne. Ist das nicht
aus Game of Thrones der Benutzernahme? Ist das nicht das was diese Typen auf der Insel
antworten? Warum sagen alle Ja? Ja ist das so ok. Das sagt nichts der sagt jetzt einfach
nein random. Was wer hat grad was gesagt? Ja genau und dann die Antwort drauf dachte
ich eigentlich auch. Sagen wir Chat habt ihr Delay oder hab ich Delay? Weil der Chat ist
heute so langsam was ist denn los? Ich hab das vor einer halben Minute oder so gesagt
was haben wir denn? Haben wir Delay? Nö eigentlich haben wir kaum Delay komisch. Der Chat ist
noch besoffen. Ich glaub der Chat ist einfach noch besoffen von gestern. Übrigens angeblich
ich hab jetzt total viele Videos dazu gesehen das Microsoft Windows durch Linux ersetzen
will das ist so fail heute morgen wieder ein Video vorgeschlagen bekommen. Ich bin ja fast
geneigt dazu auch mal ein Video zu dem Thema zu machen und zu sagen es glaubt ihr doch
selber nicht. Was bescheuert das? Das ist total warum sollen die das machen? Dein Mic
ist Muted. Der Heli ist aber auch doof. Der Heli fliegt obwohl er beschossen wird permanent
sinnlos weiter geradeaus. Oh nice. Und BÄÄM. Okay das war typische Battlefield Hitbox.
Es hat eigentlich so gesehen als es komplett dran vorbei geflogen aber es hat trotzdem
gehitted. Was ist das für eine Map? Ah das ist die DLC Map jaja ich habe vergessen
wie sie heißt ja stimmt stimmt. Ich hab wie gesagt Battlefield ihr kennt mich ich bin
ja nicht der große Conquest Spieler und ich hab in Battlefield 4 auch wenig Conquest gespielt
noch weniger auf noch weniger auf DLC Maps. Die Gegner sind mal wieder richtig pepega
und checken Mix. ACR Beste. Aber er spielt nicht mit Codra wie sie hier die Pros spielen
wie wir wissen alle mit Codra und nicht mit Red Dot. Weil ich will er sich auch einfach
nur schwerer machen. Was ist das eigentlich für ein FoF gerade? Also ich mein bald kann
er echt hinter sich gucken oder? 250er FoF. Da wirds mir schon ein bisschen schlecht beim
zugucken. Nice. Die Waffe sieht man wirklich sehr selten. Ist das der Engi Waffe oder ist
das eine Assault Waffe? Get schreckt. Locker Locker ist ja quasi so das Metro von Battlefield
4. Ha! Wie der Typ einfach vor Mordek sprung ist.
Hä? Das ist ja langweilig. Leute wisst ihr was ich glaube der hatte dieses
Jahr an Weihnachten einfach zu wenig Clips. Weil der hat jetzt schon den zweiten Clip
drin und wo er sagt das der eigentlich nicht reingehört. Wobei der ist doch richtig gut.
Guck mal da sprayt er alle richtig Hardcore weg. Der Clip ist richtig pork. Da sprayt
er alle weg. Was ist das für eine Kombination? Cobra mit Sniper krass. Das siehst du echt
selten die Kombi. Also Sniper mit Cobra sieht man sehr selten.
Ich hab gar keine Ahnung mehr wie das in Battlefield 3 funktioniert. Haben die Sniper mit Cobra
Visier überhaupt Bullet Drop? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube das war vom Visier abhängig
oder? War das so? Ja haben sie. Nein. Was war das ich? Ihr wisst dass ich kaum Sniper
im Spiel habe. Die haben das immer. Weil dieses Sway rumgewackelt haben die nur mit großem
Scope. Oh nice. Der mag irgendwie Sniper mit Red Dot und Cobra Visier. Was Fettelbild.
4 zu 3. Hat er noch am Röhren Monitor Spiel? Schreckt in den Kopf. Oh nice Collateral.
Hab ich auch nicht gesehen. Ok das ist Console. Das sieht so kacke aus und scharf das muss
Console sein. Ja gut. Also das Ding treffen wenn es da einfach rum steht kann ich aus.
Kann ich auch. Guck mal das ist auch Console aber sogar mit ganz guter Grafik.
Schreck. Oh. Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht er hittet. Oh.
Ich seh nix. Was ist da?
Was? Moment was passiert da überhaupt? Ich hab noch nicht mal gesehen auf was er geschossen
hat. Ah da da steht was. Guck mal da. Hab das gesehen.
Was ist? Alter was ist Boden? Was ist Gegner? War es gut Michael? 5 Spiele an. 144 Spiele.
Man sieht es ja kaum.
Oh nice. So Clips sind immer cool. Aber trotzdem man erkennt ja wirklich nix.
Er hat wirklich nix. Also bei dem Letzten hast du wirklich nix erkannt.
Nö. Nein auf gar keinen Fall. Ich mein was bringen Clips wo man nix erkennt. Ist doch
komplett komplett sinnlos. Ja ich hab ja drauf geachtet dass die Quali
halbwegs passt. Leute da hast du wirklich gar nix erkannt.
Du hast Hunger? Ja ich hab auch Hunger aber bei uns dauert es bestimmt noch ne Stunde
bis was gibt oder so. Oder vielleicht sogar länger.
Ok das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an. Moin. Er hat glaub ich kein Bock mehr auf Black
Ops 5. Musst grad überlegen was es ist.
Auf gehts. Na garantiert das ganze Game ist voll mit irgendwelchen
Top Lobbies Hacker möchte gern Hacks werden. Konnte Livestream mit Black Ops 2?
Wahrscheinlich nur auf der Xbox One. Wobei Moment Xbox One Black Ops 2 Schwachsinn.
Black Ops 2 war 360 ne. Der Klo. Das ist bei Black Ops 2 bin ich mir nicht
sicher ob die die Kugel fake ist. Die Map in Black Ops 1 ist aber definitiv fake.
In der Map in Black Ops 1 steht irgendwie eine Million Spieler drauf.
Alles die Reverse Boosting Map. Das ist da wo sie immer ich glaub das ist die Map wo
sie sich immer selbst gekillt haben zum Reverse Boost in Black Ops 2.
Hm. Exzellent. Legit Player. Legit Player.
Das einzige was die Black Ops 2 patchen würden ist wenn wieder das falsche Bild auf der Toilette
hängt oder so. Sowas sowas sowas wird immer gepatcht ne. Aber das Game ordentlich machen
ne ne ne ne. Schreckt. Ah ja legit legit aim. Der aimt aber gut mit nem Controller da Typ
muss man echt sagen ne. Und es laggt.
Es laggt halt wirklich. Und ja das ist so der Unterschied zwischen PC und Konsole also
man ich red jetzt nicht von Auflösung und sonst was. Du merkst das auch Connection
mäßig. Das ist echt heftig. Aber gerade bei diesen alten Call of Duty Dingern am besten
war am besten war wenn du Black Ops 1 gespielt hast und du hast halt einfach so lange gewartet
bis du Host wirst. Du hast alles geohnt als Host in Black Ops 1.
Oh ist das dumm. Ja man konnte damals lagswitchen um Host zu werden. Schreckt.
Heya Biner. Heya Biner. Das war doch das Game oder? Das war doch Black Ops 2.
Oh es laggt. Das stimmt. Der Xbox One Controller oder jetzt halt der neue Xbox S Controller
der mag ja objektiv gesehen besser sein aber ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber mir
gehts so ich komm mit dem 360 Controller viel besser klar als mit dem Xbox One Controller.
Beim Xbox One Controller fühlen sich die Sticks so übersensitiv an. Keine Ahnung ich kann
es schlecht beschreiben und so klein auch. Alles klar alles klar.
Es hat geklopft.
Es läuft mega schlecht siehst du ja auch grad. Das laggt as fuck. Und das hattest du gerade
in Call of Duty auf den alten Call of Duty Teil auf der Konsole. Wenn du einen besseren
Ping hattest oder noch schlimmer wenn du Host warst die Gegner sind in dich reingerannt
während du auf sie geschossen hast. Das heißt die haben es noch nicht mal mitgekriegt
dass du überhaupt da bist bis du sie gekillt hast. Dass man überhaupt derankt werden kann
ist halt der Witz nur wenn das alles kleinzeitig gespeichert wird. Richtig hängen geblieben.
Da ist der Schneiber im Fenster. Das sah aus. Ja die Black Ops 2 Voice Lines waren auch schon
in Call of Duty 3. Ich glaube die haben halt keine Spieler mehr in Cold War. Die machen
noch nicht umsonst jeden Tag Doppel XP. Genau das sage ich ja auch schon die ganze Zeit.
Wozu Skill-Based Matchmaking? Quick Play, einfach Public Random Bash und dann kann
man eine Ranked Playlist machen weil dann kann man wenigstens ein bisschen Schwanzvergleich
machen mit seinem Rank. Das ist dann auch ok dass da gespitzt wird ohne Ende. SPMM ist
für alle beteiligten Kacke. Sogar für die Leute die schlecht sind. Oh, weggesprayt.
Er leckt ein bisschen rum. Äh ja, kann man sich geben. Oh, sieht ein bisschen gemoddert
aus. Lead-Hacks.
Sieht aus wie Vector aus der MW2. Das ist auch Vector. Ah ok, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ich kann mich kaum noch an die Waffen in dem Game erinnern. Ah ja ja.
Die Maps sind halt auch schon, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich finde ganz, also meine
persönliche Meinung, ich finde Black Ops 1 hatte richtig gute Maps, Cold 4 hatte richtig
gute Maps, MW2 hatte teilweise, hatte recht viele ganz ok Maps, aber die hatten teilweise
in MW2 auch schon so merkwürdige Sachen wie Trailer Park und sowas, wo du von 30 Millionen
Leuten angeballert werden kannst, MW3 naja, Black Ops 2 auch ganz gut, aber ich muss euch
ehrlich sagen, Black Ops 1, Cold 4 waren für mich so, äh Dings und Cold 5. Cold 5 hatte
auch coole Maps teilweise. Teilweise nicht alle. Und das hatte mit die besten Maps und
die besten Maps waren nach wie vor die, die irgendwie eine logische Struktur hatten, wo
du im Kopf überlegen konntest wo die Gegner sind. Weil generell ist Call of Duty Multiplayer
schon immer fucking random gewesen und wenn du da noch random Maps hast, dann ist halt
für'n Arsch.
Deswegen, deswegen Blackbird. Blackbird war glaube ich nur 7 Kills, ne? Ein total OP.
Erschreckt. Mit Bobbus gesprayt. 8. Stimmt 8. Hardline mit Hardline mit Hardline 7. Oder
waren's mit Hardline 8 und 9 normal. Weiß das gar nicht mehr genau. Also Black Ops hab
ich immer gespielt, äh, URV Blackbird Hunde oder sowas in Kombi, das war beste. Oh, das
war close, das war close. Poggers streaks. Ey Leute, ich sag's euch, wenn ich, wenn ich,
ich hätte jetzt das Pech gehabt, dass der mich gemessert hätte. Der Typ hätte mich
jetzt in diesem Moment hätte der mich gemessert. Gepannic Knife hätte er mich. Zwei Aus- und
Aufreger früher. Oh, da werden sie weggesprayt. Die Eier geballert. Oh, die wären geschreckt
die Gegner gerade. Die Wauzis. Oh, das war so cringe damals. Die Kumana Krieger Wauzis.
Damals hab ich gecringe dabei, obwohl ich noch nicht wusste, dass es cringe heißt
überhaupt. Oh, die Gegner waren ja richtig gut. 1 zu 14, 2 zu 15, 2 zu 12. Exquisite
Gegner. Was ist die Ein-Vier-Launch? Das war, ah. Das, das war, da wurde es
geflamt mit Shotgun. Er steht da einfach random rum natürlich. Oh. Richtig schön
pepega aim. Wenigstens, wenigstens geht es nicht nur mir so. Ich hab ja manchmal auch
so pepega aim Momente. Übrigens wisst ihr woran man gutes aim erkennt? Ich, ich, ich
drop, ich drop jetzt mal hier die richtigen, die richtigen Massive Knowledge Bombs. Man
erkennt gutes aim nicht daran, dass einer mal gute, gute Shots hittet oder so. Man erkennt
gutes aim an Konsistenz. Und nicht weil man irgendwie crazy Shots trifft ab und zu aus
losgelöst aus dem Kontext. Konsistenz ist das was gutes aim ausmacht. Was, warum ist
der nicht tot? Wie bei Nudeln. Exakt. Warum ist der mal am ersten schon nicht gestorben?
Die Hit, die Hit-Rack ist teilweise übelst merkwürdig mit Shotguns in dem Game.
Der, hat der Fabian nicht damals ein Video gemacht in Black Ops 1, wo er Prestige 10
Level 60 oder was das höchste war, wo er das letzte Game was er gebraucht hat für
Rank Up mit so ner dreckigen Shotgun Klasse gespielt hat und trotzdem alle gebashed. Ich
erinnere mich noch dunkel. Mit Stake Out war das. Guckt mal fällt euch auf, in dem Game
haben sie noch Waffenlizenzen gekauft. Später machen sie das nicht mehr, weiß auch nicht
warum. Heute ist es die Pellington und sowas. Oder Holger, die Holger. Anstatt die UMP.
Oder war Holger G36? Ich bring's grad durch ihn, Alter.
Schreckt. Wundert mich nicht, er hat einfach das Game hochgeladen, wo er off poppt. Oh,
der rennt voll in die Granate, Alter. Alter, brain lag. Ja, klar. Gerade Call of Duty
Multiplayer macht halt richtig extrem heftig Bock, wenn du alles zerstörst. Das ist halt
nun mal so. Sobald du alle auf den Sack kriegst, kannst du nicht länger als zwei Runden spielen.
Deswegen kann ich auch Cold War und Modern Warfare nicht lange spielen, weil das so anstrengend
ist und nie richtig gut so. Ich glaub das einzige, wie man Cold War und Modern Warfare
spielen kann, ist, wenn man irgendwie auf Clips spielt. So nach dem Motto, hey, so einfach
mal so irgendwie vier, fünf, sechs coole Kills hintereinander und das dann halt klippen
und für Sachen verwenden, weil so richtig oft konsistente High-Kill-Games geht halt
schlecht. Ich mein, man kann mir keiner erzählen, dass die Gegner jetzt großartig Spaß hatten,
aber nächste Runde könnte es für einen von denen schon wieder so aussehen. Allerdings
muss man sagen, das sind die normalen Stats in der Skill-Based-Matchmaking-Lobby, ne? Das
ist sonst immer so. Ah, yes. Exzellent, sehr gut. Brave Browser, based or botnet? Ich glaub,
Brave Browser ist an sich ganz ok. Komm, wir gucken uns mal an, was der Aua zu sagen hat.
Der ist umgezogen, ne? Das ist neu. Ich hoffe, der macht mir dann ein Sellout-Product-Placement
im Video. Der liest die mit Abstand am besten vor. Das ist Produkt XY, das ist das Beste,
was es auf der Welt gibt, unter allergeilste Hersteller und es gibt euch die krasseste
Performance, Super Killer Fatality Headshot Pro und jetzt geht's weiter mit dem Video.
So, der macht die Sellouts immer am besten. Ich habe euch ganz recht herzlich zu einem
neuen Video, auch zum ersten Video quasi in meinem neuen YouTube-Studio, was ihr im
letzten Video beim Umzug schon gesehen habt und ja, ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt, lasst
mir gerne mal Feedback über Ton und Bild da, weil es jetzt eine neue Kamera ist. Es
hallt ein bisschen, ich glaube, das liegt gar nicht mal, das liegt wahrscheinlich mit
am Raum, aber vielleicht als Mikrofon ein bisschen näher dran machen müssen oder so,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es großartig störend ist. Das ist das gleiche Mikrofon,
aber Kamera ist jetzt eine neue, also sehr, sehr gerne Feedback zu dem ganzen Ding. Übrigens
habe ich auch die Kabelkanäle jetzt grau gestrichen nach dem ganzen Feedback von euch.
Exzellent. Ich hoffe, das ist jetzt auch zu eurer Zufriedenheit geworden. Wäre mir
gar nicht aufgefallen. Kurz darauf gehe ich auch noch ein, das war auch im letzten Video
zu sehen. Mein Kabelkanal ist an einer Stelle total kaputt und ich habe jetzt einfach halt
den Monitor so da vorgestellt, dass man es nicht sieht. Das neue Intel-Verpackung ist
das der Rocket Lake 11900K, leider nein. Da war ein Geschenk von Intel drin, das ist dieses
Teil, was da an der Seite steht. Das ist eine Intel Tiger Lake CPU, also quasi ein Notebook-Chip,
aber das ist quasi der weihnachtliche Intel-Bestechungsversuch. Leider noch kein Rocket Lake. Heute machen
wir so ein bisschen. Ich habe Kabelkanäle, ja. Zwei, drei Themen. Ich habe mir extra
einen legen lassen, hinten vom Mini-Server-Raum hier vorne, da waren sie zum Computertisch.
Die von mir noch nicht angesprochen wurden dieses Jahr 2020 und was mich so ein bisschen
noch stört als Abschluss 2020 in der ganzen Industrie, sage ich mal. Was mich stört ist,
dass ich mir jetzt schon seit einem Jahr einen neuen Rechner kaufen will und jetzt
wo die neue Hardware draußen ist, die ich mir eigentlich kaufen würde, wenn man sich
nicht kaufen kann, und wenn man sich kaufen kann, kostet das dann einfach 1000€ mehr
und das sehe ich nicht ein. Abschlussvideo dieses Jahr. Wir fangen an mit dem ganzen
Thema Verfügbarkeit, RTX 30 und AMD-Grafikkarten, dann kurz Hardware-Unboxed-Thematik, da wurde
ich häufig danach gefragt und dann, wie gesagt, noch was Kleines, das ich ansprechen möchte
und würde sagen, damit geht es auch los bei diesem Video. Resizable Address Register,
das ist die Technologie, die eigentlich hinter dem sogenannten AMD SAM Smart Access Memory
steckt, wo die CPU auf den Grafikkartenspeicher zugreifen kann, was laut ASUS Real-World-Performance
bis zu 13% mehr Leistung bieten kann. Das Ganze wurde bei AMD mit R6 6800er Serie vorgestellt
und bei der Vorstellung dachte man, dass es eigentlich ein AMD-exklusives Feature ist
und ASUS hat es jetzt geschafft, dass dieses Feature auch für Intel-Mainboards verfügbar
ist. Das bedeutet, alle mit R6 6800er Serie-Grafikkarten können jetzt mit einem BIOS-Update den
Resizable Bar-Support im BIOS aktivieren, nach dem BIOS-Update, zum Beispiel wie bei
einem Maximus 12 Xtreme, 700€ Mainboard oder sowas bestimmt. Also falls ihr ein aktuelles
ASUS-Mainboard habt mit Intel 400-Serie-Chip-Satz, dann könnt ihr dieses BIOS-Update jetzt
machen. Die ganze Liste und alles findet ihr natürlich auf der AUSUS-Webseite bzw. auf
der Website für euer betroffenes Mainboard. Aber ich hab ja gar kein ASUS, ich hab ja
kein SROC-Mainboard. Und außerdem hab ich die falsche Serie dafür an CPUs. Und wir wissen,
dadurch sind die Preise auch enorm gestiegen und sind ganz anders als das, was Nvidia angekündigt
hat, was wir alle natürlich gehofft haben. Und das schauen wir uns jetzt nochmal ganz
kurz so ein bisschen im Detail an, weil mir so ein bisschen der Blick auf die Sache fehlt
von vielen Leuten da draußen in den Kommentaren. Also es wird natürlich unfassbar viel gebashed
und teilweise auch zurecht. Aus meiner Sicht geht das Ganze nur gegen die Hersteller. Also
Nvidia und AMD haben logischerweise absolut Bashing verdient an dieser Stelle, weil beide
Lounges halt einfach mal wieder wie alles aktuell in dieser Industrie unfassbar schlecht
gemacht worden. Es wird einfach immer so viel Hype generiert und dann schafft man es als
Hersteller aber nicht irgendwie Verfügbarkeit zum Start zu haben, sondern es muss alles
immer schön rausgerusht werden, aber es ist am Ende nix da, was man kaufen kann. Es ist
ultra ätzend, es zieht sich aktuell durch die ganze Industrie, es ist auch egal, ob
das jetzt Cyberpunk ist oder ob das eine von den anderen ist. Guckt euch Early Access Games
an, da wird auch rausgeprügelt und dann wird irgendwann festgestellt Calquait, das Game
ist dab, bevor es rausgekommen ist. Einfach mega ärgerlich und wenn wir jetzt mal speziell
den RTX 30 Fall betrachten, dann mal so ein bisschen zum Blick, warum die Preise so sind,
wie sie sind. Viele, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das nicht sehen wollen oder nicht sehen können,
wir fangen jetzt mal an kurz mit der 1080 TI, also mit der Nvidia Pascal war das ja.
Bei den Grafikkarten oder zu diesem Zeitpunkt, als diese Grafikkarten am Markt waren, gab
es halt diesen ganz riesengroßen Mining-Hype. Ja, ja, da hatte ich Glück, da hatte ich Glück
Leute 1080 TI, die habe ich noch von Nvidia gekriegt, da hatte ich Glück. Danke nochmal
Nvidia, Poggers. Da habe ich auch noch mehr Videos gemacht. Bitcoin Mining haben, vielleicht
dieses Jahr, vielleicht, vielleicht mache ich dieses Jahr wieder so viele Videos und
paar Views, dass es wieder interessant für Nvidia ist.
Für uns Gamer absolut ätzend war, für die Leute, die Bitcoin abgecashed haben, für
die war es wahrscheinlich cool. Glückwunsch, falls du dabei bist. Ja, aber für uns Gamer
war es auf jeden Fall eine ätzende Situation. Nvidia hat zu diesem Zeitpunkt unfassbar
viele 10er Generationen Grafikkarten produziert, also 1080 TI und so weiter und dann stand
ja die RTX 20 Serie ins Haus, also die sollten veröffentlicht werden, aber man hatte noch
quasi die Lager voll mit den alten Karten. Was macht man dann? Warum hast du die von Nvidia
bekommen? Weil ich ein Video drüber gemacht habe. Richtig krass, ein Sellout mit dem Titel
natürlich auch, easy, so muss das sein. Hat sich im Endeffekt keine Sau angeguckt, das
war so 24K für irgendeine neue Grafikkarte, aber warum nicht? Das Video hat kein Mensch
interessiert, aber kann ich ja nichts für, wobei man sagen muss, ganz ehrlich, so schlecht
ist das gar nicht. Also die meisten Sponsoring-Videos kommen ja nicht so gut an wie die normalen
Videos, weil die Leute natürlich checken, dass das was komplett anderes ist als das,
was du sonst machst und dafür ist ungefähr zwei Drittel bis Hälfte von den normalen
Videos absolut in Ordnung. Kann man sich eigentlich gar nicht beschweren. Und zumal ich finde
ich auch noch, was das Ganze recht fair gemacht habe, weil Game Stream von der 1080 TI ist
wirklich geil zum Fernsehen rüber. Gucken wir uns erstmal den Aua fertig an. Man verkauft
die RTX 2080, 2080 TI einfach viel viel teurer als sie ursprünglich geplant war. Und das
macht man deshalb, weil die Grafikkarte jetzt nicht unbedingt besser ist, sondern weil man
einfach besser differenzieren möchte zwischen den zwei Generationen. Weil es ist einfach
so ein ganz subjektives Ding, wenn man weiß, das Ding ist einfach unfassbar viel teurer
als die vorherige Generation, dann denkt man automatisch so ein bisschen, die ist auch
besser. Und wenn man jetzt betrachtet zu 87, 89, 1080, diese ganzen Generationen hatten
ungefähr ähnliche Performance Sprünge, auch ähnliche Preisunterschiede, da hat sich
die 2080 nicht mehr. Plötzlich 20er Serie extrem viel teurer und dadurch hebt man natürlich
den ganzen Markt an. Dadurch wird natürlich der Preis für FPS grundsätzlich einfach
teurer. Zumal die 2080 gar nicht so extrem viel besser als die 1080 TI war. Böse Zungen
haben ja behauptet in Nachhinein, dass die 1080 TI quasi zu schnell war. Und das hat
man wie gesagt hauptsächlich gemacht, weil eben viel 1080 Karten noch verfügbar waren
und dann war die 2080 da und dann hat man von denen ganz viel gehabt, dann hat Nvidia
unfassbar viel Promotion gemacht für dieses ganze RTX Thema, RTX On überall, weil man
ja versucht hatte die Karten zu verkaufen, trotz, dass sie ja nicht so viel schneller
waren als die 1080, 1080 TI und trotzdem doch zu teurer waren.
Und letztendlich muss man halt sagen, dieses ganze RTX On Zeug, das ist so ein nicees Ding
nebenbei, aber jetzt der Seller schlechthin ist es für mich jetzt nicht.
Und dann oder darin besteht ja auch das ganze Problem mit der 30er Karte, weil dann, wenn
man dann an einer neuen Karte arbeitet, wie jetzt eben die RTX 30 Serie und sie ist deutlich
schneller. Deutlich, deutlich schneller als die vorangehenden Generationen und sie ist
viel, viel günstiger. Zumindest in den Köpfen von den Videos.
Da haben die Leute geflamed, aber das habe ich damals schon nicht verstanden, warum die
Leute so geflamed haben, aber das liegt auch daran, ich komme halt noch aus der Generation,
jetzt kommt wieder Hallo Boomer. Ich beschwer mich nicht, wenn ich eine Grafikkarte
zwei Jahre verwenden kann. Für mich ist zwei Jahre Grafikkarte verwenden
das höchste der Gefühle. Mittlerweile kann ich eine Grafikkarte vier
Jahre verwenden und sie ist immer noch gut. Aber das ist nicht das, wie ich das früher
gewohnt war. Ich beschwere mich im Leben nicht, wenn ich nach zwei Jahren eine Grafikkarte
bekomme, die schneller und billiger ist als meine.
Ja, dann gesagt krass, hier RTX 3080 MSRP 700 Dollar. Und das ist das Problem. Man kann
sowas machen, wenn man zum Lounge 5 Millionen Grafikkarten vielleicht hat. Dann kann man
den Markt beschwemmen und kann sagen, okay die ganzen 2080.
Aber wisst ihr was am geilsten war? Die Leute, die vor dem Lounge, das ist ja auch richtig
fähig gewesen. Die Leute, die vor dem Lounge oder während dem Lounge von der 30er Serie
dann ihre 2080 Super und 2080 auf Ebay verkauft haben. Für ein Apel und ein Ei. Könnt ihr
euch da noch dran erinnern, wo es auf einmal auf Ebay massig viele 20er gab?
Grafikkarten, die droppen natürlich preislich ins Nirwana runter. Aber wenn man so eine unfassbar
schlechte Verfügbarkeit hat, dann kann das Ganze einfach nicht funktionieren. Weil euch
muss ja klar sein, der Wert eines Produkts, ist jetzt egal ob es ein Grafikkarten ist
oder irgendwas anderes, der wird nicht vom Hersteller bestimmt, sondern vom Markt. Von
Angebot und Nachfrage. Die meisten von euch kennen das. Schule, 5. oder 6. oder 7. Klasse,
keine Ahnung.
Auf der anderen Seite ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht, dass ich mir jetzt noch keinen
neuen Rechner gekauft habe. Weil ich hätte mir höchstwahrscheinlich eine 3090 gekauft.
Einfach weil es geht. Kennt mich ja mittlerweile. So und eventuell kommt eine 3080 TI heraus
nächstes Jahr. Oder nein, sorry, dieses Jahr. Wir haben ja erst der 1. heute. Und dann kaufe
ich mir vielleicht die.
Irgendwann gab es mal dieses tolle Angebot-Nachfragediagramm. Normalerweise ausgewogen irgendwo pendelt
sich eben der Marktpreis ein. Das dauert immer so ein bisschen bis sich das einpendelt.
Irgendwann hat man hier diesen Punkt. Und dann weiß man ganz genau, alles klar, so ist
das Angebot, so ist die Nachfrage. Hier ergibt sich eben der Preis. Bei der 3080 ist es eben
ganz ganz anders. Da hat NVIDIA gesagt, wir würden das gerne für 700 Dollar anbieten.
Aber der Markt hat gesagt, die Grafikkarte hat einen viel, viel höheren Wert. Weil und
das muss man einfach neutral betrachtet sagen, eine 3080 hat einen höheren Wert als 700 Dollar.
Einfach nur, weil die Leute bereit sind, so viel zu bezahlen.
Da ist was dran.
Aber dazu kommt natürlich auch, dazu kommt natürlich auch, dass so wenig lieferbar sind.
Und dass dann die Leute sagen, okay, dafür, dass ich jetzt doch noch eine bekomme, gebe
ich auch mal mehr Geld aus.
Die Grafikkarte hat in unfassbarer Menge von Shops gekauft und teurer verkauft worden.
Teurer verkaufen kann man nur, wenn es Leute gibt, die das bezahlen. Und damit ist ja der
Marktpreis gegeben. Und er ist gegeben aus Angebot-Nachfrage, Angebot unfassbar schlecht,
Nachfrage unfassbar hoch. Dadurch steigt eben der Preis.
Und deswegen kaufe ich mir halt einfach keinen neuen Rechner, weil ich sehe es nicht ein.
Mein neuer Rechner wird eh nicht billig. Ich sehe es nicht ein, 1000 Euro mehr auszugeben.
Einfach nur, weil gerade alle durchtrennen.
Die Leute nicht mal verurteilen. Ich kenne auch den einen oder anderen, der hat sich
eine Karte gekauft, hat sogar angefangen damit zu zocken und dann kamen andere an und haben
gesagt, ey, ich gebe dir einfach 400 Euro mehr für deine 3080 oder 3090. Ich kann keinen
verübeln, der für 400 oder 300 Euro mehr seine Grafikkarte verkauft und kauft sich zwei,
drei Monate später wieder eine andere. So ist es eben einfach. Man kann den Marktpreis
nicht diktieren als Hersteller. Das funktioniert eben in der freien Marktwirtschaft so nicht.
Und dessen müsst ihr euch auch bewusst sein.
Ich aktuell spiele ich in 1080p. Ich bin ja aber auch so jemand, der auf Low Details
spielt für mehr FPS. Sogar Battlefield 3 spiele ich auf Low. Ich bin aber ehrlich gesagt
am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht, falls es da was Gescheites gibt, als nächstes einen 21
zu 9 240 Hertz kaufe. Gibt sowas schon? Gibt sowas schon und was kostet sowas?
Kostet wahrscheinlich 1000 Euro oder so.
Hast du da? Ja. Happy Omen. Kost. Geht doch eigentlich. Geht doch eigentlich. Es ist
für den Monitor nicht wenig Geld, aber geht doch eigentlich. Ist doch okay. Moment, was
hatten der überhaupt für einen? Achso, das ist 16 zu 9. Ja, mal gucken. Aber ich behalte
meinen Monitor jetzt eh erst noch ein bisschen. Ich habe ja erst vor einem halben Jahr oder
so den Monitor gekauft. Ich habe ja, ich habe mir hier, warte. Thank you. Den da gekauft
vor einem halben Jahr. Davon gibt es jetzt übrigens eine neue Variante. XL2546K gibt
es jetzt im Prinzip das gleiche, nur mit irgendwelchen komischen Colorbooster, Blah, sonst was.
Braucht kein Mensch. Könnt ihr mir mal erklären, warum die Verpackungen immer so schäbig aussehen?
Nicht die erste Monitorverpackung, die ich bekommen habe, die so ultra schäbig kaputt
aussieht. Letztendlich war nichts kaputt. Alles top. Aber Monitorverpackungen sehen irgendwie
oftmals total schäbig dreckig aus. Jetzt gucken wir erst mal den Auer fertig. Hinter
den Leuten, die ihre Grafikkarten teurer verkaufen, den Vorwurf machen, noch den Händlern, sondern
rein Nvidia und AMD, weil die eigentlich nicht gebacken bekommen. Ja, das stimmt. Richtig.
Da hat er recht. Also ich mache jetzt in dem Händler keinen Vorwurf. Ich finde es zwar
ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, ein bisschen fies, wenn ich die Grafikkarten jetzt für
1000, aber ich würde es als Händler auch so machen, klar. Warum soll ich weniger Geld
nehmen, wenn ich kann? Ich würde auch Prime-Subs nehmen, wenn ich welche bekomme. Warum soll
ich mich wehren dagegen? Sondern dementsprechend auch Verfügbarkeit vorhanden ist. Und das
ist einfach das große Problem. Und ich hoffe, dass sich das in der Zukunft so ein bisschen
verbessert, weil das ist ja nicht nur bei den Grafikkarten so, sondern es zieht sich
für die ganze Industrie, dass die ganzen Hersteller immer so absolut beschissene Lounches machen.
Ja, das stimmt. Danke schön, DennisG011. Danke schön für den Sub. Plus plus IQ plus
plus. Und es wird gefühlt von Jahr zu Jahr schlimmer. Natürlich jetzt durch die aktuelle
Corona-Situation wird das Ganze nicht besser. Wir haben kein Sub-Command, aber wenn es dich
interessiert, es sind jetzt, ich gucke mal nach, Leute, es sind jetzt 276. Soni-Sun oder
Sunny-Sun. Twitch Prime. Danke schön für den Sub. Noch mehr Chat-IQ plus plus. Ja,
also ich gäbe ihm voll und ganz recht. So sieht es aus. Ja, logisch. Thema abgehackt.
Er hat mir gerne mal wissen, oder lasst mich gerne wissen, was ihr zu diesem Thema gemacht
habt. Seh ich genau so. Ich würde es als Händler auch so machen. Was für ein Ding? Anzeige
ist raus. Ach, Sus. Ah, Sus. Und das Ganze hat Hardware Boxed ja dann
veröffentlicht und das ganze Internet ist komplett ausgerastet. Ich würde mir ganz
ehrlich, also okay, ich habe absolut, ich habe das null mitgekriegt, aber ich weiß
nicht, ob ich sowas veröffentlichen würde. Keine Ahnung. Auf der anderen Seite könnte
man sagen, ja, Nvidia möchte ihnen keinen Test-Samples mehr geben. Ich weiß ja nicht
auf welcher Basis das so läuft. Ob das Test-Samples sind in Form von, du bekommst es, musst du
wieder zurückschicken, oder ob das quasi so Sponsoring-Geschichte ist, wo ich meine,
ich muss meine ja auch nicht zurückschicken. Oder Scam-Trains. 69 Leute. Seht ihr das?
Hier. Also auf keinen Fall Subben. Das muss so stehen bleiben. Jace2Sense, Linus Tech-Tipps,
alle komplett eskaliert. Bei mir auch massig Kommentare auf dem Kanal, ob ich mich dazu
äußere und wie mein Standing zu Nvidia dazu ist. Und ich muss sagen, ich war ziemlich
überrascht von der Reaktion im Netz. Also, ich weiß es nicht. Wow, was ist jetzt los?
Alter, MonkaS. Huge. Der Tribulon hat 5 Subs gegiftet. Poggers. Tribulon, Dankeschön.
Wir hatten was gekriegt. HorstibrossAKNN15, Snitcher, Baba, Boyboss. Alles klar. Happy
Printer TV. Und jetzt hat noch einer gesagt, nämlich Makes, was? Moment. Makes no sense
Dota. Ah ja, könnte man auch für Hearthstone sagen. Danke schön für den Prime-Sub. Ich
glaube, ich glaube, Leute, wir haben jetzt fast, wir haben bald 300 Subs geschafft. Wenn
wir 300 Subs schaffen, dann kriege ich, glaube ich, noch einen neuen Emote-Slot. Kann das
sein? Ich guck mal kurz. Ich guck mal kurz, Leute. Wartet mal. Wartet mal. Ich guck mal.
Ich schau mal kurz. Jellystar, Twitch Prime auch. Dir, Dankeschön für den Sub. Ich
muss mal kurz gucken. Ich finde in diesem Control Panel nichts. Dieses Control Panel
ist so unübersichtlich. Also wir haben, also ich habe aktuell 28 Emote-Slots. Setzt sich
zusammen aus 18 normalen Emote-Slots und jeweils 2x Tier 2, Tier 3 Emotes. Und ich krieg den
nächsten Emote-Slot bei 450 Abo-Punkten. Das sind keine Abos. Das ist so ein Twitch Sub
Points Twitch. Das ist so ein komisches, so ein komisches System, was ich bis heute nicht
gecheckt habe, ehrlich gesagt. Warum man das nicht einfach, einfach in Abos macht. Subscriber
Points. Hier. Also. Subscriber Points. 450. Das heißt, ich brauche. Ja, wie viel brauche
ich denn? Wie viele Subscriber Points sind denn? Was? Emote-Slot 26? What? Ach nee,
das ist das andere hier. Nein, nein, nein. Das sind nicht. Das sind Subscriber Points.
Das ist nicht so. Guck mal. Zum Beispiel. Das ist nicht gleich Subscriber. Das verstehe
ich irgendwie nicht. Ich glaub nicht. Ich checke es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Ich hab, ich
bin dazu zu Low-Brain. Tier 1 gleich 1 Sub-Point. Ist das echt so? Okay Leute, dann dauert es
echt noch ein bisschen, bis ich einen neuen Emote-Slot kriege. 450 Tier 1 Emotes. Da
sind wir noch ein bisschen davon entfernt. Da müsste ich, dass ich das packe, da müsste
ich den richtig krassen Sell-Out fahren, sage ich euch. Muss Massive Sell-Out machen. Alle
5 Minuten Sell-Out. Und Raid Shadow Legends. Das hat aber gerade noch jemand gesubbt. Groove
Electric. Danke schön für den Sub. 4 Monate schon. Massive Subscription. Wir kriegen
übrigens im nächsten Mal noch mehr Emotes. Wir haben ja seit gestern oder vorgestern
haben wir ja welche. Weiß nicht, ob ihr es schon gesehen habt. Tier 3 Subs gibt's. Guck
mal hier. Tier 3 Sub. Paints-Champ. Komm wir haben neue Emotes. Wir haben jetzt Woop-Prime,
Woop-Leak und Woop-Boom. Den finde ich ja irgendwie cool. Die sind alle nice. Wir kriegen
noch mehr demnächst. Patrick meint als nächstes gibt's Lull, Lull, Gasm und Pock. Woop-Boom
brauchen wir auch noch. Temporary Mongoose Twitch Prime. Danke schön für den Sub.
Oh, der Train ist abgefahren Leute. Level 3 Complete. Jetzt geht's mit der Runde hier.
Das ist eigentlich, wenn man es mal genau nimmt, der übelste Scan. Das ist fast so ein
bisschen was wie auf der Casino Seite. Leute mögen einfach instinktiv Balken, die nach
oben gehen. Deswegen, glaube ich, machen auch so viele mit Terrorkicks. Danke schön für
die 100 Millionen. Das Leute mögen einfach Sachen, die einfach Balken, die raufgehen.
Und Zeit, die runterläuft. Na gut, das ist ja, kennt jemand noch diese neuen Live-Geschichte?
Was war das? Der Hot Button? Der Red Button? War da nicht Knossi sogar früher mal? Ach,
keine Ahnung. Irgendwie, wo alle immer eskaliert sind. Warum ruft denn keiner an? Und dann
ist die Sirene angegangen. Alarm, Alarm. Und keiner ruft an. Das ist doch so einfach.
Auf dem Discord sind die Twitch-Emails übrigens doppelt vorhanden. Oh, da muss der Cute-Mod
mal gucken. Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Hups. Jetzt hab ich irgendwie, wo waren wir
denn? Moment, wo waren wir? Zwei, drei Monate später wieder eine andere. Auf Raster-Performance
als auf Tech-Tipps, alle komplett eskaliert. Hier, waren wir. Bei mir auch massig Kommentare
auf dem Kanal, ob ich mich dazu äußere und wie mein Standing zu Nvidia dazu ist. Und
ich muss sagen, ich war ziemlich überrascht von der Reaktion im Netz. Also, ich weiß
es nicht. Also, je nachdem. Ich kenn diesen Fall nicht. Aber sind das Test-Samples, die
ihr danach wieder zurückschicken muss, dann find ich's fragwürdig, nur weil einem die
Art nicht gefällt, dass man ihn nicht mehr beliefert. Wenn das so Sponsoring-Zeug ist,
dann kann ich es in gewisser Weise nachvollziehen und dann würde ich es auch nicht öffentlich
machen. Weil, da hat natürlich der Hersteller ein gewisses Interesse daran, dass man ihn
nicht schlecht dastehen lässt. Haltet mich für irgendwie komisch oder sowas, aber warum
hat ein YouTuber ein Recht auf eine Karte? Ja, hat er komplett recht. Sehe ich das falsch?
Ich weiß es nicht. Er hat original Recht. Wie gesagt, ich würde es unterscheiden, ob
das Test-Samples sind für eine Test-Plattform, die objektive Tests veröffentlicht und es
danach wieder zurückschickt. Wobei behalten ist, dann ist es kein Test-Sample. Oder ob
das ein Sponsoring-Ding ist. Und bei einem Sponsoring-Ding kann ich verstehen. Wie gesagt,
ich habe auch, sofern das jetzt nichts übertriebenes war, aber bisher die Sachen, die übertrieben
waren, wollte, habe ich nicht gemacht. Aber bei mir war es auch so, da hat Nvidia gemeint,
ja, man muss unbedingt Nvidia im Titel groß schreiben und ja, man muss hier das verlinken
und jenes und so. Ah ja, dann mache ich das doch.
So, wenn ein Hersteller was promoten möchte, am Ende ein Hersteller möchte sein Produkt
verkaufen. Und natürlich sucht es sich die Wege aus, wie sein Produkt am besten verkauft
wird. Ja Moment, oh Landherrn, wenn das Hardware-Seiten sind, die das reviewen sollen, ok, das ist
was anderes. Ich rede ja auch nicht von Test-Samples, ich rede von so Sponsoring-Sachen und dann
kann ich verstehen, dass das Nvidia nicht bockt oder nicht geil findet, wenn sie schlecht
dargestellt werden oder nicht so, wie sie es gerne hätten. Und dann ist es vollkommen
unlegitim an der Stelle, als Nvidia, wo gesagt für Sponsoring-Sachen, zu sagen, ne das unterstützen
wir dann nicht. Denn wie gesagt, den einzelnen Pfeil habe ich jetzt nicht mitgekriegt, dann
ist ok. Wenn man die Sachen dann bekommt, testet und wieder zurückgibt, ist was anderes.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele hunderte Tech-YouTuber da draußen und Nvidia wird sich auch denken,
gut, wenn einer weniger eine Karte bekommt, ist ja genauso, wenn ich keine Karte bekomme,
dann ist das eben so. Weil ich eben vielleicht nicht den typischen Launch-Content produziere,
den anderen machen, dann gibt es eben keine Karte. Das ist ganz normal, weil die natürlich
das versuchen, so gut wie möglich für ihren Sale irgendwie umzusetzen. Deswegen war ich
schon ein bisschen überrascht, dass natürlich, ich kann Hardware-Inbox verstehen, dass die
das veröffentlicht haben, aber dass dann alle anderen YouTuber und auch die ganze Community
so hart darauf gebashed hat, dass dann Nvidia zurückgerudert und sagt, ok, kein Problem,
nächste Generation gibt es wieder was. Echt? Ernsthaft haben die zurückgerudert? Ich hätte
erst recht gesagt, Alter, jetzt gibt es nichts. Es ist schon ein bisschen verrückt, dass man
irgendwie so die Macht hat zu sagen, ich hätte gerne... Aber die Macht der Empörung ist deutlich
höher heute, als man glaubt, ja. Also was man alles durch pure Empörung heutzutage durchsetzen
kann, ist krass. Also ich würde sagen, Empörung geht heute deutlich über Fakten und Sinnhaftigkeit.
Gratis Samples möchte ich eigentlich gar nicht aussprechen, aber wie kommt es mir so
ein bisschen so vor? Dazu muss ich auch sagen, irgendwie kam es mir auch so vor, dass Nvidia
gebashed wurde, weil sie die Wahrheit gesagt haben. Weil ich wette mit euch, also da würde
ich meine Hand für ins Feuer legen, dass es bei vielen anderen Firmen, bei vielen anderen
Produkten genauso läuft, weil als Hersteller schauen die sich an, wer promotet mein Produkt
am besten und der bekommt das Produkt. Gab es eigentlich was Gutes beim CCC? Ich habe
keine Ahnung, ich habe nix geguckt. Ich habe mir ein bisschen die Agenda angeguckt und
das hat mir nicht zugesagt dieses Jahr. Wenn ihr dann anfragt und eins haben möchtet, dann
sage ich zu dem... Die Tagesordnung meine ich. Sorry, alle Samples dieser Generation sind
schon raus, nächste Generation vielleicht wieder. Und das hätte Nvidia ja auch sagen
können, wenn Hardbox nächste Generation anfangen könnte. Genau, Nvidia hätte einfach nix
sagen können, einfach sagen können, nee, sorry, diesmal nicht. Und sagt, ich hätte
gerne eine Karte, dann sagt Nvidia, oh sorry, alle Samples sind schon raus, dann wäre nie
was passiert. Aber ich glaube, es ist denen auf die Füße gefallen, weil sie ehrlich
waren und ich habe solche Vorhergehensweisen, sage ich mal, schon ganz oft mitbekommen, aber
das wird halt sonst nicht so offen kommuniziert. Deswegen fand ich das schon so ein bisschen
lustig und auch irgendwie ein bisschen komisch. Aber lasst mich gerne wissen, was ihr von
dieser Thematik haltet. Und was mich persönlich noch so ein bisschen genervt hat dieses Jahr,
es geht in eine ähnliche Richtung, auch mit quasi Samplesanfragen und nicht... Ja, passt
für mich, sehe ich auch so. War es ja schon immer, aber zumindest war der Content schön
ausgewogen. Du konntest einfach die ganzen Feministentalks, konntest du skippen und konntest
dir einfach Technik angucken, aber mittlerweile ist das, weiß nicht. Vielleicht bin ich einfach
auch nur zu Boomer geworden, das liegt an mir. Ich will mich damit einfach nicht beschäftigen.
Alle Mainboard-Hersteller, Asus, MSI, Gigabyte, die versuchen mittlerweile nicht nur Mainboards
zu verkaufen, sondern jeder hat da seine, keine Ahnung, Netzteile, Kühlung, Gehäuse,
die machen ja mittlerweile alles und mitmachen meine ich nicht, die machen es selbst, sondern
die lassen... Die machen ihr Logo drauf. Anderen Firmen produzieren, kommt der Sticker
drauf und dann wird es vertickt. Und ganz oft ist es jetzt so, wenn ich jetzt irgendein
Projekt habe und sage, ich würde gerne von euch dieses Mainboard verwenden, da kommt
aber dann diese Grafikkarte drauf und von dem anderen Hersteller die AIO, dann sagen
viele Hersteller, das passt uns nicht so. Du könntest ja auch Unsuche verwenden. Überleg
doch mal, ob du lieber uns das nimmst und falls nicht, dann können wir dir das andere
vielleicht auch nicht zur Verfügung stellen. Was ich verstehen kann, ich kann es ja wirklich
verstehen, weil aus Sicht vom Hersteller macht das absolut Sinn, den eigenen Kram zu promoten
und nicht das von der Konkurrenz, ist natürlich für uns als YouTuber immer ein bisschen anstrengend.
Ich persönlich denke mir dann einfach, okay, wenn die das nicht wollen, dann kaufe ich
das selber, ich mache da kein großes Drama draus. Das kannst du aber halt auch wirklich
nur machen, ab einer gewissen Größe. Er kann das machen, ich denke mal, er hat auch andere
Einnahmequellen noch, da pappt nicht umsonst überall, da bauert das Bauerlogo drauf und
so. Aber sagen wir mal so, als vielleicht jetzt nicht ganz so, ja, komplett gut aufgestellter
YouTube-Channel wird es halt schwierig mit alles kaufen.
Passiert das eben ganz, ganz viel und das ist im Prinzip die gleiche Richtung wie das,
was bei diesem Nvidia Hardware Unboxed Thema. Hat er eigentlich Merch? Keine Ahnung. Könnte
ich mir vorstellen. Wäre auf jeden Fall, wäre auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, weil sein Name
ist bekannt.
Wenn sich das groß verändern wird, es wird höchstens die Aussage eine andere werden.
Also dann sagt eben der Herrscher nicht mehr die Wahrheit, sondern sagt eben, keine Ahnung,
haben wir gerade nicht da, kann ich den gerade nicht schicken.
Ist übrigens, wisst ihr was mir dazu einfällt? Da muss man auch, wenn man Arbeitgeber ist,
übelst darauf achten, dass man nicht mal angenommen, ja, also man hat gegen den Bewerber was, weil
man, keine Ahnung, echt rassistisch, antifeministisch, was auch immer ist, ja. Also man angenommen,
es ist ein Arbeitgeber, der sagt, er will keine Frauen einstellen oder so. Oder er will
keine Schwarzen oder Ausländer einstellen. Aber angenommen, das gibt einen Arbeitgeber,
der so drauf ist. Was total bescheuert ist, weil der Arbeitgeber sich dadurch selbst
quasi eventuell guten Leuten beraubt, ja, also was beknacktes. Aber trotzdem. Und man
angenommen, das gäbe es, wenn der das sagt, ist, Anzeige ist raus. Wenn der aber einfach
nur sagt, ach, die Chemie zwischen uns hat nicht so gestimmt oder irgendwie so, der Bewerber
hat mich nicht überzeugt, das ist okay. Also, es wird oftmals nicht gerne gesehen, wenn
jemand die Wahrheit sagt, weil die Wahrheit halt oftmals, ähm, sehr unangenehm ist. Und
das auch nicht gerade, auch ehrlich gesagt gerade für den Arbeitgeber in dem Fall spricht,
ja. Also klar, das wird dazu führen, dass man immer mehr sich drum herumdrückt, um
ehrlich aussagen. Terrorkeks hat ein Abo geschenkt, an Zipfel, 18,94, Dankeschön.
Das sollten die Leute auch mal im Hinterkopf so ein bisschen behalten. Ja, das waren so
kurze zwei, drei Sachen, die ich noch mit euch besprechen wollte, am Ende von diesem
Jahr. 2021 starten wir mit einem sehr interessanten Thema, wir starten auch direkt mit dem Notebook
Kühler, den ich Ende des, oder, sag mal, Mitte Dezember mit euch schon mal kurz besprochen
habe, wo wir den 3D-Metall gedruckten Notebook Kühler hatten, das, oder? Exquisite. Oh, ich
krieg Hunger, Leute. Ich krieg richtig Hunger. Wisst ihr was, was richtig cool wäre? Ich
sag jetzt mal. Also mal angenommen, ich krieg's wirklich gebacken, nächstes Jahr, weiter
halbwegs regelmäßig YouTube-Content zu produzieren und wir machen auch weiter Stream und alles,
also ich, was mega geil wäre, wenn ich irgendwie schaffe 450 Abos hinzukriegen. 450 Abos wäre
einfach Massive Pog. Dieses Jahr, dieses Jahr, nicht nächstes Jahr, 0W, dieses Jahr. Ich
glaube, übrigens, ich glaube, ich weiß, wozu ich heute noch ein Video aufnehme, oder morgen,
mal gucken, weil ich sehe total viele Sachen, die sich gerade damit beschäftigen, ob Microsoft
replace Windows mit Linux. Das ist so, das ist so fail. Wirklich? Hä? Ich hab doch heute
morgen noch, Moment, ich guck mal kurz in meine History. Ich hab doch heute morgen noch
ein Video empfohlen bekommen und das ist nicht das einzige in dieser Richtung, was ich empfohlen
bekommen hab. Moment, Library, watch later. Ach nein, nein, nein, die Titel sind, die
Titel sind anders. Microsoft turn Windows into Linux war das zum Beispiel. Das da. So
Dinger krieg ich laufend empfohlen in letzter Zeit, was totaler Bullshit ist. Das ist totaler
Schwachsinn. Ich mein, die werden weitermachen in der Richtung mit WSL. Nach neun Minuten
sagt er einfach nein. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich labert er. Es ist Quatsch, null. Wozu? Nein,
die sind doch nicht bescheuert. Die werden doch nicht so eine Krücke wie Wine aufbohren.
Microsoft wird den Kram, wenn schon, ordentlich programmieren, weil sie wissen, wie es Windows
funktioniert. Also hoffe ich mal für Microsoft zumindest. Aber Wine dürfte ja architekturmäßig
eines der größten Katastrophen aller Zeiten sein. Nein, das wird sich Microsoft garantiert
nicht geben. Okay, is Brave based or botnet? Ehrlich gesagt verwende ich Brave seit zwei
Jahren nicht mehr. Also was Microsoft machen wird ist meine Prediction. Ich gehe auch davon
aus, dass Microsoft mehr in Richtung Linux gehen wird. Sieht man ja jetzt schon. Ja,
auf Azure. Das meiste auf Azure ist Linux. Also was da drauf läuft. Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
die Infrastruktur unten drunter natürlich auch. Weiß ich aber nicht genau, vermute
ich jetzt einfach mal nur. Also das meiste, was auf Azure läuft, ist Linux. Windows mit
WSL geht auch eindeutig in diese Richtung. Die werden in Zukunft auf Serverbetriebssystemen
mit Sicherheit mehr easy Linux in der Integration bieten. Du siehst daran, dass Docker mittlerweile
schon über Hyper-V Umwege unter Windows läuft. Also sie werden immer weiter Schritte auf
Linux zu machen. Und ich gehe auch davon aus, dass du, dass das Ziel von Microsoft ist,
dass du die Vorteile von Linux unter Windows verwenden kannst und nicht umgedreht. Also
die werden nicht dafür sorgen, dass du quasi Windows unter Linux verwenden kannst. Die
werden dazu, also nicht, dass du Windows Software unter Linux verwenden kannst. Die werden dafür
sorgen, dass du das, was die Leute dazu bringt, Linux zu verwenden, dass du das möglichst
einfach unter Windows machen kannst. Weil das bringt Stonks und das bringt Geld bei Microsoft.
Ja. So denke ich, dass das, dass das. Hast du das schon gesehen? Nee. Was ist das? Kann
ich denn Toss, Monka Toss, Musik? Mittlerweile kannst du ja leider auf Twitch nichts mal
zeigen. Monka Toss, Musik. Aber wir können was anderes machen. Ich habe eine Idee. Ich
habe eine Idee. Doch, ich kenne das. Kirby Gourmet Race. Passt doch fast. Fast original.
Das passt sogar relativ gut, oder?
Naja, nicht wirklich. Jetzt passt es gerade überhaupt nicht.
Der passt. Na gut, genug. Genug. Genug. So. Gibt es noch, gibt es noch irgendwas, was
YouTube uns interessantes vorschlägt? Hier, zeig mal her. Ich kriege übelst Kohldampf
langsam. Oder wie beim Osten sagt, Knast. Gibt da schon ein paar komische Redewendungen.
Der hatte, der hat auf jedem, der hat auf jedem Computer epic Sachs geil Gandalf laufen.
Ups. Gute Idee. Es gibt auch das Video, wo das jemand im kompletten Haus laufen hat.
Ja. Einfach mal auf jedem Fernseher.
Oje. Oje, Frau in der Küche. Wenn das, wenn das die Feministen sehen. Fuck. Gleich ausmachen.
Der hat es auf dem Handy laufen. Lustig ist. Könnte ich eigentlich auch machen daheim.
Ich habe gerade erfahren, um ein Uhr gibt es Mittagessen exquisite. Das heißt, wir können
noch eine Sache gucken. Oh. Aja, ja. Gaming Zimmer. Macht der Fernseher da? Das ist eine
gute Frage. Du meinst den hier, ne? Du meinst den hier, der einfach so random in der Ecke
hängt. Ja. Random in der Ecke hängen. Ja, das ist Kokona Haus. Da ist es kein Problem.
Da kannst du einfach Löcher in die Wand schneiden. Was gibt es zu futtern? Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ehrlich gesagt. Okay, das soll ich gucken. Kusswort sagt, das soll ich gucken. Gucken
wir mal rein. Was ist das? Ja, da haben wir doch schon eine Folge von Guck. Okay. Zwei
Minuten 48 können wir uns 43 können wir uns angucken. Hauptsache Essen. So sieht es aus.
Im schönen Südwestfalen ist es noch so normaler Sprecher zu begegnen. Der Vorsteher der 1000
Seelen Gemeinde Rinsdorf. 720p in 2020. Und dafür bezahlen wir Gebühren. Glauben wollen,
bis er hier unter der Talbrücke der Autobahn 45 spazieren ging und seinen Augen nicht
taute. Mein Gott, das ist ja wie das sechste oder siebte Weltwunder, was wir, dass er erstellt
worden ist. Das ist so gigantisch, das, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Unglaublich.
Mal nicht so ironisch, Herr Moos. Dieser wirklich gigantische Zaun, der ist ein echtes. Warum
steht da random einfach eine Zaun rum? Das Wunder der Natur per Nibel geplant und realisiert
mit erlesenen Baumarkt. Warum steht da einfach random eine Zaun rum? Ganz stolz auf sein Wunderwerk.
Der Mann vom Landesbetrieb Straßen NRW hat den 400 Meter langen Zaun kreiert mit Mann
und Maus. Hat er ganze Arbeit geleistet. Toll, ne? Außer dass es scheiße aussieht, bringt
es ja noch nicht mal was. Da kann es ja auch unten drunter. Warum? Ja warum eigentlich?
Hinter dem Zaun lebt die Haselmaus. Sie ist hier als streng geschützte Art aufgefunden
worden. Die Haselmaus kommt ja unter diesem Zaun auch nicht durch. Oh, dann ist aber auch
putzig. Ja, im nächsten Jahr wird nämlich von hier unten aus an der Talbrücke da oben
gearbeitet. Dann sind hier ganz viele Bagger und Arbeiter und Autos und ach und wenn die
nicht aufpassen, dann ist die Haselmaus Mause. Aber will man sich das vorstellen? Und die
Gefahr wäre groß, denn hier lebt ja nicht nur eine Haselmaus. Ja, wir haben in den letzten
zwei Jahren diese Haselmäuse oder dieses Gebiet kartiert, haben insgesamt fünf Haselmäuse
nachweisen können. Oh, ja die Chancen steigen ja immer mehr, dass da einer überfallet.
Pardon, wie viele? Fünf Haselmäuse. Ganze fünf, krasser Scheiß. Eins, zwei, drei,
vier, fünf Haselmäuse, aber dann ist der Schutzzaun ja gar kein siebtes. Ja komm,
wer bezahlt dafür nicht gerne Steuern? Also ich, ich gebe, ich gebe ehrlich zu, ich gebe
ehrlich zu, also wenn ich schon Spitzensteuersatz bezahlen muss, dann bin ich doch wenigstens
froh, dass die Haselmaus geschützt ist. Du, du bezahlst das. Zumindest zu nem Teil.
Du, der Steuertager. Ja. Dat auch noch. Dat auch noch, ja. Auch das noch. Mensch, freut
euch doch lieber, dass das Baumarktzaunwunder ein Schnäppchen war. Wir haben jetzt hier
für dieses Schutz dieses Biotops, was rund ein Hektar groß ist, rund 30.000 Euro. Ich
hoffe die Haselmäuse werden dann hier einen ruhigen Lebensabend verbringen. Aber sicher,
blöd nur, wenn die Haselmäuschen die Löcher unterm Zaun entdecken würden. Naja, aber das
wäre dann ja wirklich das Wunder von Südwestfalen. Tja. Oh, das ist schon Fail. Sowas können
wir gut zu bürokratische Dinger. Obwohl das ja nicht mal wirklich, wirklich bürokratisch
ist, das ist einfach so über, über korrekt voraus, vorauseilende Dinger gemacht, die
eigentlich total sinnlos sind. Guckt ihr mal das an Best of neuen Life. Oh, nee, nee, nee,
nee, nee. Das ist kein RTL Stream hier. Hier ist High IQ, High Big Brain Stream. Da können
wir keinen neuen Life gucken. Das geht nicht. Neuen Life ist IQ minus minus. Und wir haben
schon so viele Subs bekommen. Für IQ plus plus, das funktioniert nicht. Das geht jetzt,
klappt nicht. So, noch irgendwas, was man noch mal kurz zehn Minuten lang gucken kann.
Die Abgründe des Online-Journalismus. Also, die Abgründe sind, dass es in Spielen, also
einer der Abgründe ist, dass es in Spielen mittlerweile Game-Journalist-Modes gibt. Übrigens,
das Schlechteste, Leute, das wollte ich euch zeigen. Kennt ihr das Schlechteste? Spiele-Tester-Game-Journalist-Gameplay
aller Zeiten. Es ist so dermaßen schlecht. Cuphead-Shameful-Gameplay. So. Und das ist
kein Fake. Ich dachte am Anfang, das ist Fake. Ich dachte, das ist Fake. Das ist aber kein
Fake. Das ist wirklich einer, der sein Geld mit dem Spielen und Berichten und Bewerten
von Spielen verdient. Wie benutzt du diese Better-Twitch-TV-Emoves? Es gibt zwei Varianten,
magst du Tant. Also, entweder installierst du das da. Addon. Du brauchst erstmal das
passende Addon dafür. Entweder installierst du FFZ oder du installierst Better-Twitch-TV-Addon,
aber ich empfehle dir, mittlerweile macht es eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied mehr,
weil beide beides können, aber ich empfehle dir FFZ. Ich persönlich finde FFZ besser.
Du installierst dir das da und dann gehst du in die Settings und schaltest diesen ganzen
Mist ein. Dann gehst du in die Settings, zu Addons, Better-Twitch-TV-Emoves und machst
alles an. Wichtig ist, dass du auch GIF-Emoves einschaltest. Und dann kannst du dir die ganzen
Sachen angucken. So, also kommen wir mal zum schlechtesten Gameplay. Das ist jetzt kein
Gameplay, das ist wirklich einer, der Geld mit Videospielen verdient. Es reicht, wir
gucken uns keine 16-20 Minuten an, wir gucken uns nur mal die ersten paar Minuten an, aber
man muss sich, wenn man sich dieses Video anguckt, muss man sich echt überlegen, das
ist ein professioneller Videospiele-Journalist, der das spielt hier. Das ist das Tutorial,
wo man die Controls beigebracht kriegt. Und an der Stelle dachte ich mir, das muss fake
sein, das muss fake sein. Aber das ist kein Fake, das ist kein Fake. Das ist kein Fake,
das ist einfach Unfähigkeit pur. Ich mein, wundert es irgendjemand, dass man jetzt noch
einen Schwierigkeitsgrad für Spieletester einbaut mittlerweile? Der ist in echt bestimmt
auch ein Cuphead, ja. Ne, ne, ne, ne, das Tutorial hat er gleich durch. Hier kommt gleich
noch mal das Gameplay. Ja, ich mein springen und dann Y drücken, ich mein das wird schon,
das ist schon wirklich verdammt hart. Warum hab ich eigentlich Jepp und ihr nicht? Weil
ich Jeppen darf und dann chat nicht. Weil ich Jepp nicht mag. Jepp ist Suck-E-Mode,
Alter. Dafür habt ihr Zedge. So, gleich schafft das, jetzt schafft das glaube ich, jetzt
schafft das glaube ich. Fast, fast, er lernt, er lernt Leute, er lernt, er lernt. Ja, falsche
Richtung. Er lernt, er lernt. Oh, fast, fast. Die hieß Evolving, ja. Fast, er hätte es
fast geschafft. Das kann nicht wahr sein, doch. Die haben, mittlerweile haben sie die
Website Description auch aktualisiert, ja. Auf der anderen Seite ist das eigentlich richtig
Big Brain Werbung für die Seite, ne. Oho, Porgas. So, und jetzt, ok, wir skippen das
mal, guckt mal wie er das normale Level spielt. Das ist richtig krasser Pains Champ. Meint
ihr, meint ihr, er schafft das erste Level? Überlegt euch mal, ihr werdet direkt vom
ersten Mob in diesem Spiel gehitted. Der Chat ist im Weg? Quatsch, sieht man noch alles.
Aber er checkt, er checkt es langsam, ja. Das ist so schlecht, das ist so schlecht.
Also, wenn man hier unten mal durchguckt, der schafft es nicht. Er schafft es nicht.
Er schafft es erst, er schafft es gar nicht bis zum Boss, glaube ich. Er schafft es nicht.
Er kann es einfach nicht. Guck mal, er kann es einfach nicht. Das Game ist schwierig,
ja, aber nicht das. Guck mal, er kann es einfach nicht. Nach 20 Minuten, nach 20 Minuten,
kriegt er es immer noch nicht gebacken. Das ist echt Painful, oder? Ja, und er kriegt
Geld für das Game. Also, er kriegt Geld fürs Spiel. Aber man muss sagen, er wird ein bisschen
besser. Also, da wundert es mich nicht, dass man wirklich Spieletester, Gamejournalist
Difficulties einbaut, ja. Das ist so nervos, wie es... Die Lernkurve, die Lernkurve ist
in dem Fall flach, ja. Er hat ein bisschen was gelernt. Ey, man muss ihm zu gut halten,
er spielt sowas normalerweise nicht, aber ganz im Ernst. Das ist ein bisschen so, wie
wenn jemand zum ersten Mal Super Mario spielt. Der wird vielleicht die ersten Eins für Anläufe
mal ein bisschen Probleme haben und dann wird er mit der Zeit das eigentlich hinbekommen,
aber er hat es dann nicht hinbekommen. Der Kerl war doch deren Wirtschaftsjournalist.
Ich kann es dir ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, er ist auf jeden Fall jemand, der sich normalerweise
nicht mit Jump'n'Runs beschäftigt. Aber er wurde hingeschickt als, was er normalerweise
macht, Wirtschaft, keine Ahnung, aber er wurde auf eine Spielemesse geschickt für Games.
Also, das ist schon echt der Wahnsinn. Gute Promo für das Spiel. Letztendlich gute Promo
für das Spiel und gute Promo für die Seite, weil es gibt, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, wenn
ihr im Internet wirklich Feedback haben wollt, ob das, was ihr da macht, gut oder schlecht
ist oder ob das Hand und Fuß hat oder wie auch immer. Ihr dürft die Leute nicht fragen,
so nach dem Motto, könnt ihr euch das bitte mal angucken, wie findet ihr das? Ihr müsst
einen Blog-Artikel drüber verfassen oder einen Reddit-Post darüber verfassen, dass
so, wie ihr das gemacht habt, die beste aller Varianten ist und dann könnt ihr euch darauf
verlassen, das gesamte Internet wird sich drauf stürzen und nach Fehlern suchen. Wenn
ihr einfach nur nach Feedback fragt, funktioniert das nicht. Sagt ihr aber, hey Reddit, so macht
man das und so ist der beste Weg ever, dann kommt ganz Reddit an und sagt, nein, nein,
nein, also in Zeile 2 hast du was Falsches gemacht, in Zeile 3 hast du was Falsches gemacht,
das geht so auch nicht, das ist auch falsch, das ist auch falsch. Also es gibt kaum einen
größeren Drang im Internet, als andere Leute darauf hinzuweisen, dass sie falsch liegen.
Es gibt ja nicht umsonst dieses Meme, wo der eine Typ um 3 Uhr nachts aufsteht, so nach
dem Motto, ich habe eine Nachricht bekommen, jemand hat was Falsches im Internet gepostet,
ich muss darauf antworten. Die haben das auf ihrer Webseite hochgeladen, ich glaube der
Typ hat es dann hochgeladen, was ich auf YouTube. Genau, wenn du sagst, Max, ich finde, da liegst
du falsch, verspüre ich jetzt instantly den Reflex, dir zu erklären, warum ich nicht falsch
liege und so weiter. Nee, ist aber echt so. Also wenn ihr legit hören wollt, was gut oder
schlecht ist oder besonders was schlecht ist, macht einfach einen Reddit-Post und sagt,
dass ihr es besonders gut gemacht habt. Ganz Reddit wird sich auf euch stürzen und euch
erklären, warum es scheiße ist. Und generell der Reflex, andere Leute im Internet zu korrigieren
und darauf hinzuweisen, dass was nicht stimmt, ist auch geil. Das ist immer so, wisst ihr,
wenn ich ein Video mache, sagen wir jetzt mal, nehmen wir mal beispielsweise, irgendwie random
ein Video, keine Ahnung. So, dann sagen wir das Video. Ich mache jetzt ein Video, 20 Minuten
und lasse mich über ein Thema aus. Und ich habe mich in einem Satz versprochen oder noch
besser, ich habe in einem Satz aus versehenden Wort verdreht oder so. Du kannst Gift drauf
nehmen. In den Comments sind mindestens 20 Leute, die sagen, also Max, bei 3 Minuten
30 musst du die Aussprache aber nochmal üben. Immer, so ist es normal. Du kannst das perfekteste
Video machen. Die Leute finden einfach was. Oder, ach Max, du hast ja überhaupt keine Ahnung. In
Wirklichkeit ist das so, so und so. Und das, was sie schreiben, ist im Prinzip zu 99% das,
was ich auch im Video gesagt habe. Naja, so sieht es aus. Exzellent, exzellent. Leute,
ich gehe jetzt Mittag essen. Ich habe Hunger. Max, das heißt nicht 20, sondern 20. Exzellent,
so sieht es aus. Barbecue Pit Boys zum Schloss. Nee, ich gebe jetzt Futter, ich muss jetzt runter.
Es ist kalt. Ich weiß ja nicht, was es gibt. Manche Sachen schmecken kalt nicht. Also Leute,
wir sehen uns vielleicht nachher nochmal eine Runde, aber ich glaube, ich nehme nachher
eine Runde Video auf. Wollen wir mal gucken. Wir sehen uns. Machts gut, bis denn, CU.